Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
Now
I'm a cybernetic organism.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs.
When your business needs a logo,
website,
business card,
thumbnail,
or any other design.
I recommend checking out 99 designs.
I use them myself.
I've used them for many years.
I used them to create book cover prototypes for the four hour body,
which went on to becoming number one New York Times bestseller.
I've also used them for banner ads,
illustrations,
and much more.
With 99 designs.
You get a variety of original designs from designers around the world,
give your feedback and then pick your favorite.
Your happiness is guaranteed.
So check out some of my competitions in designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss.
Show listeners@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash.
Tim and right now you can get a free $99 upgrade on your first design.
So check it out.
99 designs.com forward slash.
Temp
so it is brought to you by headspace.
More than 80% of the people I've interviewed,
world class performers across the military,
entertainment,
sports,
and beyond all have some type of meditative practice.
I tried for years and years and failed miserably.
The key is making it simple and you can dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and technology can help you.
This change comes through guided meditation and headspace is by far the most
popular app for this purpose.
More than 4 million users.
It's meditation made simple,
so what I recommend is that you take this practice meditation,
which is rooted in thousands of years of tradition,
supported by thousands of scientific studies and try it for 10 minutes a day for
10 days.
That's all you need to do.
You could also check out the founder Andy Puddicombe,
a Ted talk,
which has more than 5.5 million views.
His last name is p,
if you want to look that up,
but otherwise,
download the free headspace APP.
I have it on my phone and begin their take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation.
Completely free.
10 minutes a day.
That's all it takes.
You should give it a shot.
headspace.com forward slash Tim just go to headspace.com forward slash Tim
boys and girls.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
each episode,
it is my job to deconstruct a world class performer,
to tease out the habits,
routines,
tips,
favorite books,
etc. That you can use.
Whether that is someone like Jamie Foxx or a chess prodigy or a special
operations commander and everybody in between this episode we have Alex Honnold.
I've wanted to interview Alex for a very,
very long time.
You can find them on facebook.com forward slash Alex Honnold,
He is a professional adventure rock climber who's Free Solo.
That means no ropes,
no partner,
a sense of America's biggest cliffs have made him one of the most recognized and
followed climbers in the world.
If you want to sweat profusely from your poems,
you can watch videos of Alex and I'll put them in the show
notes@forourworkweek.com forward slash podcast.
Uh,
handled is distinguished for his uncanny ability to control fear while scaling
cliffs of Dizzying Heights without a rope to protect him.
And we really dig into that,
how he looks at risk fear addresses both in training and with these first ascent
attempts.
And so on.
His most celebrated achievements include the first and only free solos of the
moonlight buttress.
That's a five 12 d,
which means super fucking hard.
Ah,
that's 1200 feet in Zion National Park in Utah and the northwest face,
that's a five 12 a of halftone 2,200 feet and that is in Yosemite in California,
right in my backyard.
Beautiful spot.
In 2012 he achieved Yosemite's first triple solo climbing.
That means in succession,
the national parks,
three largest faces,
Mount Watkins,
half dome and El Capitan alone and all in under 24 hours.
He is the founder of the Huddled Foundation and environmental nonprofit.
And to this day,
and perhaps one of the most fascinating aspects of Alex is he maintains a very,
very minimalist dirt bag climber existence.
And that's not meant as a slight,
that is meant as a compliment living out of his van.
And I think he's done that for the last 10 years or so,
despite the fact that he has big sponsors and traveling the world in search of
the next great vertical,
adventurous.
We dig into all sorts of things.
And without further ado,
I will let you hear the wider Indian conversation that I had with Alex Honnold.
Alex,
welcome to the show.
Yeah,
thanks.
Thanks for having me.
I have wanted to interview you ever since I first saw footage of you climbing
because I trained long ago at mission cliffs here in San Francisco and did top
roping,
never have climbed outside except for castle rock.
I don't know if you know yeah,
by Santa Cruz.
Exactly.
That's where I started as a kid,
kind of really where my local area.
So you grew up in Sacramento or am I making that up?
Yeah,
I grew up in Sacramento.
And what was your upbringing like?
I mean,
if you had to describe your childhood,
how would you take a stab at it?
Uh,
just,
just normal suburban life.
You know,
Sacramento,
good times,
good times.
Sac Town.
I haven't spent a lot of time.
I mean Mark Bell who's a buddy has a gym called Super Training Gym up there.
He's,
I think one of the top 10 in his weight class of all time.
That is the extent of my exposure to Sacramento is just hanging out with him and
feeling really weak,
which probably would have been the experience if I'd gone climbing with you even
in the early days.
What did your parents do?
Um,
my parents were both teachers or professors.
What did they teach?
They taught language,
like English as a second language in French.
Where
were your parents born?
In the US or are they elsewhere?
Um,
yeah,
they were both born in the u s though mom was born,
took Polish immigrants.
So that,
I mean she's born in the u s and she's American and her parents were actually
born here too,
but they were like 100% Polish,
like fresh off the boat.
So
how did you start climbing?
I know it's probably a story that you've told a million times,
but how did that begin?
Um,
my parents just read about a gym opening in Sacramento and I thought I'd like
it.
And so they took me to a climbing gym.
I mean,
just like you were saying to the mission cliffs,
like there was a comparable jasmine and uh,
Sacramento.
And so I went in there when I was maybe 11 and then just kept going all the
time.
What was,
what was the first day like?
Can you describe like,
I honestly have no recollection.
I was like an 11 year old and then I probably went to the gym,
you know,
three to five times a week from 11 to 18.
So it's like,
it all kind of blurs into one epic gym session.
Did you know in the early days of going to that gym that you had a
predisposition to it?
Um,
no,
not particularly.
I mean,
I loved climbing and I,
I loved going in there and just playing all the time and climate as much as I
could.
But I was never like gifted in the way that a lot of people are gifted rock
climbers.
And you know,
I wasn't like winning the competitions or anything.
I did some comps on and off throughout my teenagers.
And um,
I never won.
You know,
I was never,
I was never super strong,
but I just like loved climbing all the time.
Why do you think you didn't want,
and I mean what will cause very strong,
strong,
strong meaning in what capacity?
Like I,
I like to dig into the details with the soap for example.
I mean this is kind of getting into the nitty gritty,
but,
so that's what this is about.
Okay,
here we go.
So Chris Sharma is like basically then the best climber in the world for the
last 20 years.
And he was like my hero and I was a kid or you know,
he was one of the people I watched videos of and I was like,
that guy's the man.
So he's from Santa Cruz.
He started climbing when he was 14 and when he was 15 he put up a route called
necessary evil and outside of Las Vegas.
And it was like the first 14 c in the country.
So it's,
it was the hardest route in America.
And he did it after one year of climbing as a 15 year old.
I mean,
that's like a prodigy.
I mean he was like freakishly strong from the get go.
He could just always pull on really smart because he had freakishly strong
fingers.
He could do one arm pull ups off like anything.
And you're like,
that guy's gifted.
Um,
I was not that guy,
you know,
actually this season I tried to do that route necessarily equal this winter and
I totally fell about it.
She's like,
I still couldn't do it.
And I was like,
God damn.
I been climbed for 20 years and I like try pretty hard,
you know,
and I still just can't climb as well as he did after one year.
While I still can't climb as hard.
Like I'm just not as strong as he was after one year.
I mean,
there are plenty of things that I'm probably better at than he is,
you know,
it's all relative technique and everything.
What would I,
what would some of those things be that you're better at?
Well,
I've actually,
I mean not to necessarily compare you to him.
You're very good at.
He's never done in the Alpine climbing.
He's never really done any big wall on.
And he's probably not super efficient logistically and um,
you know,
but he's very,
very strong and I'm just not strong like that,
but,
you know,
but I do other types of climbing.
For those people who are not familiar with the world of climate,
could you describe some of the different types?
So the Alpine big wall climbing is,
it's pretty complicated because it ranges from say indoor bouldering,
which is probably the simplest thing you can possibly do.
Um,
to Alpine climbing,
you know,
a climbing in the Himalaya or climbing huge walls around the world.
And so that involves like ice and mixed climbing where you using ice tools and
crampons and that kind of gear.
And then,
you know,
there's big wall climbing,
which is basically climbing huge vertical rock where you're on the wall for
multiple days.
Um,
then there's,
I mean,
there's just a ton of categories and the bouldering.
So for people who don't know what that is,
that's typically,
it's no ropes.
Yeah,
it's unroped.
I mean an easy way to think of it as practice climate,
right?
You know,
basically practicing movement.
So you're climbing maybe three or four meters,
maybe five Max,
you know,
but you're climbing small small heights that you're comfortable falling off and
landing on a pad and you're basically just doing really hard physical moves.
It's actually an easy way to compare it as um,
to the running world between sprinting and ultra running or something like the
spectrum of climbing ranges from short and superintendents to super,
super long but obviously low intensity.
And I've,
I've always been more of the low intensity long distance type of guy,
you know,
where some people are just freakishly strong and you were attracted to that
because of the,
the relative lack of strength there.
Was there something else that appealed to you about that?
Um,
I dunno,
I mean I think it might just be one of the things that I've sort of naturally
gravitated towards the thing that suits me.
But I dunno,
I mean,
I think part of it is just that I've always loved climbing.
I like doing a lot of rock climbing and so I've always been attracted to high
volume.
I mean,
I liked it,
like take the roots in my guide book,
you know,
it'd be like,
oh,
I climbed this and I climbed that.
And so I like to climb a lot of roots.
So it's just,
yeah,
I mean I just,
I like climbing a lot.
It's certainly clear.
I,
uh,
I wonder what,
what do you think you were going to be or what did you fantasize about becoming
when you grew up?
When you're a kid?
I mean,
as a kid I thought I was going to become an engineer or something,
you know,
I just thought I'd have some normal job.
And um,
I mean when I was growing up,
there really wasn't a professional climbing scene.
Like you couldn't really be a professional climber cause the whole climbing
industry hadn't really taken off and there weren't so many gyms and it was like
a different world.
So I never thought that I was going to be a climber.
I just thought that I'd have some random job.
You,
uh,
now I'm going off the Internet here.
So that's,
that's a risky business.
But you ended up at one point at was a UC Berkeley.
Yeah.
Planning to be an engineer.
Yup.
What type of engineering?
Um,
I had applied for civil engineering.
I was,
yeah.
Why Civil?
Uh,
I mean basically one of my uncles was civil engineer.
I was just like,
that's cool.
And I love,
I liked building things.
And the idea of like building bridges or like big,
big projects like that.
I mean,
it's appealing,
you know,
the idea of like constructing something.
Cool.
Do you,
did you collect anything as a kid or do you I was way into Legos.
Legos.
Okay.
So this is like the old,
right.
So the kind of large structures,
large walls,
uh,
how long did you collect the Lego's for?
I mean,
do you have any idea?
I'm not looking for timelines here,
but why?
Don't know when I first started getting lagers,
but probably when I was really small and then up until being a teenager,
basically I had a ton of Legos.
Did you have any,
any like uh,
I'm not coup de Gras is not the right expression here.
I'm looking for like your landmark pieces or anything that you remembered.
I like I had friends who built like the death star at a Lego's and that was like
the pinnacle of their Lego career.
No,
I mean I think I had a few just epic Fords and like really cool pirate ships and
things.
Um,
no,
but I never constructed anything that was like the culmination of my Lego Lego
career.
I don't know.
Mean the thing is I think I took it almost as much pleasure and destroying the
things afterwards,
you know,
cause you treat it like this elaborate city and then my sister and I would take
like a golf ball or something and just like destroy it and be like,
oh it's starting over.
It's more of the process of building.
And that was so fun.
And you have one sibling or do you have more than one older sister and older.
How much older?
Two years older.
Do you talk to her much?
Yeah,
we're,
yeah,
we're good friends.
Very shy.
Fairmount?
Yeah.
What does,
what does she do professionally?
Um,
I dunno.
It's complicated.
It's basically just like makes the world a better place.
Um,
she's,
she,
uh,
she's lived in Portland since you went to college there and she's like,
Vegan has never owned a car.
She's like ultra are thirsty and um,
she basically does outdoor participation stuff with kids and uh,
it's kind of like,
I don't even know.
She's basically getting like at risk.
It's like a work program for at risk youth or sort of,
I dunno.
It's like a whole thing.
Yeah.
But over the years she,
she's also been like a middle school teacher and she's done like,
you know,
bike programs with kids and all kinds of,
wholesome things that make,
make the community better.
If you had to pick a fixed location and we'll,
we're definitely going to get to the van and everything surrounding that story.
But if you had to pick a place to park up in the u s for say five years,
yeah.
Let's just make it a five year timeline.
Where would,
where would you pick this point?
I don't know.
That's a tough,
that's tough.
But,
um,
I mean the obvious choices as a climber would be somewhere like boulder,
Colorado or say Salt Lake or Flagstaff or any of the cities that are sort of
know or Las Vegas actually places that are known as climbing hubs where you have
great outdoor climbing all around them.
And I could see living in any of those places if I had to.
Um,
or like say,
you know,
I got married to somebody that lived there or something crazy and I'm like,
well,
I could see,
I could see being happy in any of those cities.
Um,
the honesty,
I love Portland too though.
There's no real climb in there and it's not a great place to,
to live as a climber.
And the climate is terrible with too much rain.
But as far as progressive cities that go,
it's like probably my favorite city in the country.
The voodoo doughnuts too.
Unless your family know I've been there.
And I was like,
yeah,
you know,
I didn't think it was that great though.
Not the best.
Yeah.
I was like,
I was a little underwhelmed.
Yeah.
Could have been my blood alcohol content at the time.
But,
uh,
do you think,
so I want to talk about,
uh,
climbing and the ability to climb full time because you,
you touched on I think a really important point,
which is when you began climbing the prospect of becoming a professional climber
just didn't really exist.
Right.
As a notion.
I mean,
there were a handful of professional climbers when I started,
but it was like such a small,
there wasn't like a climbing industry.
It was really small.
Exactly.
Yeah.
And uh,
you have a reputation for,
or you're well known for living as,
and this is a term I hadn't heard until I watched a documentary that Yvon
Chouinard was in a dirt bag.
So living as dirt bag climber,
can you describe that?
What does that mean first of all,
and what is your version of that?
Um,
well,
so I mean,
I guess that just means somebody who is like a lifestyle climate,
like someone who just lives to climb.
So it's like the full time on the road,
you know,
doing whatever it takes to be a climber,
I guess.
I mean,
being a dirt bag isn't,
isn't a negative thing.
And the climbing community,
which is like,
oh,
that guy is committed to the cause.
And I'm sure there's the same kind of term for like the surf community or
whatever else,
you know,
people who just like live to go mountain biking or surfing or whatever,
taking odd jobs and just like doing their thing just to,
to be able to do their sport as much as they can.
And it seems,
I remember years ago I chatted with Steph Davis when I was wearing on the four
hour body.
It seems like a very semi monastic lifestyle.
I mean,
you're,
you're really dedicated.
Makes me think of like the marathon monks in Japan.
Uh,
but instead of,
you know,
running every day you're climbing sort of this itinerant lifestyle.
Uh,
now you live,
do you currently you still live in a van?
Yeah,
I mostly live in my car,
but then I'm overseas a lot more now.
And then when I'm traveling for work stuff,
I got to put up in hotels or whatever.
But,
um,
but yeah,
I mean I'm still focused in the van.
What kind of Van?
Well,
I just sold my old man,
so I lived in a van for nine years and then I just hold the two,
one of my cousins cause I was just kind of over.
I felt like I sort of outgrew it.
Um,
and so now I have a,
uh,
dodge pro master,
which I can stand in,
which is a big,
big upgrade.
How telling my wife I'm like five 11.
What,
so how have you have you kitted out this van to be suited to your needs?
So I actually just left it with a friend of mine who built it out while I was on
an expedition to Patagonia this winter.
And so he just made it nice.
I mean,
you know,
super nice bed and like a kitchen and good cabinetry and um,
a refrigerator and um,
yeah,
I mean it's basically a really small apartment.
It's super nice and uh,
the coming back to the industry.
So,
uh,
are there people who criticize the industry of climbing is sponsor influx.
And the reason I bring that up is not because I'm critical,
it's because I've seen,
for instance,
in the UFC and MMA when in the very early days it was,
it was really unfeasible for people to be professional MMA athletes.
And as soon as sponsors came in and you had that sustainability,
the level of athleticism and training and competency just went completely
through the roof.
Is,
is there something similar in climbing?
I mean,
do you feel,
how do you feel about the so called climbing industry?
I mean,
I think it's,
I think great.
Um,
I mean there is obviously criticism.
I mean,
you can find stuff online from it.
You can always find traditionalist and stuff.
We were like,
this isn't the way it was when I grew up.
So I don't think it should be this way or like,
oh,
I feel like it's corrupting the art of climbing or whatever else.
You know,
the,
the having corporate money coming into the climbing world is,
is tainting the,
the artistic experience.
I mean,
whatever.
you know,
you can find criticism for it.
Um,
I think it's great.
I mean,
obviously since I'm making a living from it and I'm able to go climbing all the
time,
you know,
I'm very content with the whole situation,
but mostly I just feel like it's sort of a natural outgrowth.
I mean,
climbing gyms are becoming much more popular because people enjoy climbing,
you know?
And so if people are into it and the industry is making money than,
than power to it.
Well it's,
it also strikes me as sort of a lot of self fulfilling prophecy,
but a virtuous cycle in so much as the more people see your exploits,
Sharma people of that caliber,
the more they're inspired to try climbing,
the better the gyms do,
the more classy.
I don't,
I do not think that's,
that,
that might be true a little bit.
But,
um,
I honestly think that part of it is just having the facilities,
like the more good gyms there are in,
in urban centers,
the more people just wind up trying it with their friends or whatever.
You know,
when you have like a nice bouldering gym next to a college campus,
like everybody tries it because it's fun,
it's sociable.
Everybody has a good time and I feel like that sort of like grows the sport.
So the supply,
it helps create the demand to some extent.
But I really doubt that any particular climbing film can be responsible for like
growing the whole industry.
You know,
it has more to do with tons of people like going to gyms and trying it and
enjoying it and going more often.
Yeah,
I guess it depends a lot on a multitude of factors.
I mean with,
not to Belabor the point or the comparison to the MMA world,
but like the ultimate fighter was kind of the breakthrough for them and then led
to a lot of gyms opening.
Yeah.
I've never had anything quite that.
No,
totally.
Like I don't follow a fighting and all by,
I've even heard of ultimate fighter and that kind of stuff.
And so I don't think climbing is really had that,
you know,
there's no like big hit reality TV climbing show.
Yeah.
You know,
the actually that there were,
there have been a pitches with that kind of stuff though,
which are pretty common.
Cool.
Well,
I'd love to see the actual,
it's aliens meets bouldering or like,
yeah,
there was an ultimate solo thing.
They got like pitch to me once and I was like,
dude,
you can't just take random people off the street and like train them how to solo
for six weeks and then just like set them off of a big wall.
It's like,
you know,
I was like,
you may as well just have gladiators fighting vines in the pit.
You know,
it's like people will literally die on your television show.
Like you don't want people to,
I got TB like no,
no,
that's exactly what we want.
I'm just like,
are you guys kidding?
You know,
cause you have to ensure the show and everything.
Like no one's going to make those because like half year contestants are going
to die.
Like straight up.
I messed up.
Yeah.
We'll have,
we'll have some beers sometime and talk about exploits and televisions.
But uh,
when,
when you are getting ready to climb something that
is going to be challenging.
I'm not saying like a first descent or something like that,
but it really,
anything that you're expecting to be reasonably challenging.
What is your self talk sound like?
What is your,
do you have any sort of prep,
anything you,
ritual ritualistically said to yourself before you get going?
No,
I don't really,
I don't self talk like that,
but I'm normally,
if I'm planning on doing something challenging,
I spend the time sort of visualizing what the experience will feel like and what
the individual section that is.
So I mean with climbing there's a,
there's a component too of just memorizing the actual moves.
So I think through the sequences and make sure that I remember like which foot
to move in which order and like how to do everything.
And then,
um,
particularly if it's a free solo or something,
if I'm climbing rope lists then I'll think through what it will feel like to be
in certain positions because some kinds of movements or are insecure.
And so they're just like kind of scarier than other types of moves.
And so it's important to me to sort of think through how that all feel when I'm
up there so that when I'm doing it,
I don't suddenly be like,
oh my God,
this is really scary.
You know,
like I know that it's supposed to be scary.
I know that's going to be the move.
I know what it's gonna feel like and I just do it.
So you rehearsed that fear in a sense or reverse the sensation,
one type of which could be fear.
Yeah.
And I think through,
you know,
how airy certain positions will feel because sometimes you can be all spread out
with like the void below you and you're just like,
wow,
this is like quite the quite the air around me.
And so it's good to have like thought about that basically to think through all
potential things beforehand so that when you're up there,
there's no like unexpected thing that happens.
You know,
we were talking earlier about this,
this,
this odd looking fellow.
The white bussed over on like counter,
who is,
for those of you who don't have a visual is,
is Seneca the younger,
uh,
which was a gift.
And of course those of you listeners,
podcasts,
lot know that I'm somewhat obsessed,
uh,
compelled to read a lot of stoic philosophy and Marcus Aurelius and so on.
Uh,
how would you describe your,
okay,
if you had to take a stab at it.
I know this is a hard question,
but you're just a general,
how does your philosophy or philosophies of,
of life and living differ from most people?
Uh,
I dunno.
I mean,
I've never really thought of any comprehensive lights,
life philosophy or anything.
You know,
I don't feel like I have a particular set of principles that I live by though.
Um,
you know,
I suppose I'm pretty minimalistic and,
and,
uh,
you know,
meeting a fairly simple life.
And I mean,
I guess that's basically how I live.
I don't know.
Okay.
What are the benefits of living simply to you,
aside from the ease of travel?
But I would imagine at this point you could probably travel reasonably easily.
Well No,
I mean that's kind of it is that,
um,
yeah,
just the ease of living,
you know,
basically it just cuts away everything except for what I wanted to be.
I mean,
cause my,
my goal is basically to climb as much as I can.
And that's what I enjoy most in life is climbing.
And so everything else to some extent is a distraction from that.
And so,
you know,
I basically just cut away what I don't need.
So I heard a story and this was a friend of a friend of a friend relaying
something they hit heard.
We'll see where this is like telephone.
Yeah,
exactly.
So who knows?
But they,
they told this story about you free climbing and this is free so long probably.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
that's right.
Free solving a big wall where at some point there was some people resting.
I don't know if they're in a,
how'd he say it?
Bivouac a portaledge movie.
Portaledge the camp thing.
Right.
And uh,
and you kind of ducked your head around the corner.
We're like,
Hey,
can I borrow some chalk?
And they're like,
ah,
sure.
And giving some shock and then you're like,
thanks.
Great.
And just kind of like continued on your merry way.
Did has anything like that happened or is that just a no,
so that is a real story sort of with some details.
Okay.
Can you,
can you tell the story?
Yeah.
So I was um,
I was so long the triple link up and you somebody,
so I wasn't free soloing but I was coming by myself so I had a little bit of,
I had a small rope and I had to got here because this is an important
distinction,
so,
okay,
got it.
So solo climbing is just climbing by yourself.
Yeah,
the free soloing means that you're free climbing and free climbing means using
your hands and your feet and not using gear.
And so if you're free soloing,
it means that you're climbing with just your hands and your feet by herself.
Like no gear,
no anything.
Got It.
But so in this case I was soloing,
so I had gear and I was,
so the three largest faces and you somebody in a day.
So Mount Watkins,
which is like way up at one end of the valley.
And I'd done that first.
And then I came down and I was climbing the nose of Oak Habitat through the
night and uh,
in the logistical shuffle and the darkness,
whatever,
I forgot my chalk bag.
So I basically climbing the first thousand feet of the nose without a chalk bag.
And it was like,
we just kind of a bummer.
I mean that's definitely not ideal and it actually rained a bunch of the day
before.
So like the bottom pitches,
which are lower angle,
where like fairly wet and I was like constantly trying to dry my hands on my
shirt and it was just all kind of scary.
And so I got up to this ledge called Bolt Tower,
which is,
you know,
about a quarter of the way up the wall.
And,
uh,
there were two groups,
if you don't,
the ledge.
And two of the people were just like passed out.
And the other two guys were like cooking dinner.
And so I popped over the one side of the ledger.
I'm like,
ah,
hey.
So can I borrow a chalk bag?
And they were like,
I guess like,
no problem.
You know,
it's so what are the guys gave you this chalk bag that was like completely full
of like fresh jock.
I was so stoked.
And then I took his chalk bag and then I climbed to the top of the root and a,
and then I left it like tied to the tree on top and think I got it back.
I met him again later.
And uh,
and yeah,
so they got their chalk bag back like four days later.
Do you have a particular type of chocolate you like?
No,
but I mean,
any chalk,
it feels amazing when you've just climbed a thousand feet of wall,
you're wet,
wet.
Uh,
what is,
uh,
what's a story?
And I realize a lot of these questions are kind of out there,
but what is a story that your,
your family or parents like to tell about you?
Oh,
I dunno.
I'll buy us some time and let you think about it so well.
So one that my parents like tell about me is I was completely infatuated with
the incredible hulk when Lou Ferrigno was doing the TV show.
So I'd run into the,
into the living room when my parents said
company and rip the cushions off of the couch and throw them on the floor and
yell like the Hulk and run out.
So my mom feels like that's in some way represents like me and my totality,
which I don't know how to take,
but that's the story she likes to tell.
Uh,
anything come to mind?
Um,
I dunno.
I mean,
mom likes to talk about how I always climbing on everything as a kid and how it
was such a wild child.
But,
um,
though I honestly feel like she's kind of like,
she talks about that more now that I am an actual professional climber.
You know,
I feel like had I become an engineer,
she would instead focus on stories of like how I always love to play with blocks
or do whatever.
But,
um,
in my whole family would always tell stories about how I was such a picky eater
and how I'd only eat cheerios and bread and like whatever,
just things.
I Dunno.
But
what do you,
we were talking just during the sound check about eating,
uh,
and I'd like to talk about that for a second.
Uh,
what is your typical breakfast look like
generally?
Well,
so I've kind of gone through two main phases,
I guess.
I used to always do like an egg scramble for breakfast and now I pretty much
always do some kind of Muesli concoction with like fruit and some kind of
alternative milk stuff and like flax seed,
hemp hearts,
like random things,
sort of like a wholesome Muesli mix.
And then I asked you about lunch and do you have to say about lunch?
Yeah.
So I,
I rarely eat a lunch per say.
I've pretty much always just snack for the several hours in the middle of the
day.
Um,
normally like a couple pieces of fruit and maybe some nut butter,
um,
you know,
a bar or two or something.
And then I eat like a big dinner.
I normally do a pretty big breakfast and pretty big dinner and then just snack
throughout the rest.
Why?
Why no lunch?
Well,
the new lunch thing,
it makes sense when you're up on a wall for the day or if you're like out at the
cliff or it's just like a bunch of work to take a real meal.
So I wasn't going to get to this immediately.
Uh,
this,
this early.
This is early for me.
I'm always in pasture.
So what was that?
I that I'm always premature.
It's fun.
It's like my friend when he drives,
we call him a premature accelerator.
But that's,
that's,
that's all separate story.
Uh,
so this is from a friend of mine who's an elite athlete.
Very high level female athlete.
I'll,
I'll ask her main question first.
Actually,
no,
I'll ask the related question first.
So the food real hassle.
So the core question was what happens if you have to take a shit on the side of
a mountain?
Meaning like on so many good pooping stories.
Okay,
we can do a whole podcast on stories.
Well,
let's give them previews.
That could be the round two.
But yeah,
let's,
I,
I mean,
I was wondering why she brought it up.
I was like,
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
It goes straight to my most epic dumps story.
Yes,
please.
Okay.
So like,
uh,
two years ago,
I guess I was free soloing this root called romantic warrior and the needles,
which is actually a super mantech warrior.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's actually one of the most striking granite walls like in the world.
This is totally beautiful route on this crazy spire.
It's,
it's an amazing,
amazing route.
It's something I've thought about for a long time and it's actually quite
difficult.
And so I was going up there to free solo.
It was like kind of a big thing for me and I was wasted out.
And typically when you get to the base of it free solo like that,
if you have to poop at all,
like you have to go like,
then you know when you're the base.
But I just like,
I dunno,
it just didn't quite happen.
And uh,
and so I started climbing and that route,
the first 400 feet or so,
or like pretty moderate train.
And then it goes into like some pretty extreme terrain for the second 400 feet.
And uh,
so basically right before I got into the real stuff,
I was like,
oh,
now we're really need to shit.
I was like,
Oh man,
you know,
basically I was like,
oh,
it's about to get real up here.
And like I now I need to poop.
And so,
um,
I basically hand traversed on this little feature.
So the traverse off the root cause is really poor form to like shit on a root
cause obviously people have to climb that introverts meaning you just travelling
horizontally.
Yeah.
So I sort of just like meandered to the left 20 feet and this flake that I was
hanging off,
it was like fairly big and I had a backpack on me with like my shoes and some
water and some food,
random things that you kind of need for,
you know,
going up along route like that.
And it had some tp in it.
So I like shoved my backpack into the flake and I just like hung there off of it
and basically just took a poop like straight off the wall,
just like wall hanging and then,
you know,
like wipe tidy it up.
It was all good.
And then I put my pack back controversy I gave them and finish the root.
It's like,
so I just want to really dig into this just like it's so,
so I'm just like envisioning,
I had bats,
uh,
I grew up on long island.
We'd have these bats,
so would like crap off of the shingles and we'd be like,
where the hell is that front?
And then we'd see the bat kind of perched there.
So what's the technique here?
So you're hanging off this flake if your backpack shoved into it,
like legs straight and straddled like you don't like a mic.
Did crouch,
you know,
pushing away from the wall,
but,
and are you going like out of the bottom of your shorts?
He pulled them down,
pulled my shorts down.
Just like anything.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
I mean it's actually totally easy.
I mean,
I'd call it a space dumb spaced out.
Yeah,
a client,
we would call it like a perfect space down.
It's just like taking a dump in a free space and it just disappears.
So what are other challenges of climbing on big walls?
I said I don't let that give the wrong idea because normally you try to like poo
and better places,
you know,
preferably a toilet or at least I barely get properly at the base or you know
like being,
being responsible about it.
But like from time to time that happens,
you know,
things happen.
What are other,
what are other issues that crop up that people might not think of when you're
doing these clubs?
Well,
people frequently ask like,
what do you do if you have to pee or whatever.
Because they think,
I mean,
I think that people have the wrong impression that free soloing a big wall.
It's just like holding on for dear life the whole time.
But they're actually all kinds of little ledges like even alleged the size of
say a pizza tray is big enough for you to stand there comfortably.
No hands.
Right.
And so,
I mean that's an easy place that you could take a leak.
You could,
um,
you know,
take a sip of water,
you can eat a little bar.
And I,
in anytime I'm on a ledge,
say the size of Sofa cushion or something,
I'll basically pop my shoes off and relax my toes for a minute because climbing
shoes are quite tight.
So like your feet start to cramp after awhile.
I mean there's a lot more self care going on up there and then people might
think,
do you carry for that self care?
Do you carry any other tools and you're like,
I don't know,
nail clippers,
any particular type of like,
I'm just making this up,
like lotion or anything?
Not that you don't have that on your hands,
but,
no,
no.
I mean,
I normally just take food,
water and then a pair of say approach shoes.
I can walk down afterward.
What type of food do you bring with you?
Um,
typically I just bring,
you know,
a sports bar type.
What kind of like,
what's bar?
I'm all,
I'm obsessing again tells griddy.
Um,
I don't know.
I mean,
um,
so I used to be sponsored by Clif bars,
so I do like,
you know,
shop blocks and z bars.
I love the z bars,
a little kid's cliff bars mostly because they're kind of half size.
They're like a hundred calories and then basically tastes like a cookie.
So I can like always eat them because they're just kind of delicious.
Um,
but now I can kind of get more into like nut butters and things.
The,
the typical free solos are short enough that you don't really need like a full
hearty meal.
You can kind of get by with like a pack of shot blocks are like one little one
sugary thing to just kind of keep you going.
Um,
it's on like bigger climbs like albinism or something where you have to take
like a lot of,
you know,
fatty,
like higher calorie food.
So this,
this is actually,
I will be the first person to admit that I actually do not know what albinism
is.
Uh,
and,
but one of the questions that came up this from Kelly O'shea,
my listeners is ask Alex about his recent achievements and albinism.
Uh,
what was it like as someone who's so accomplished in one discipline to be a
beginner again in another type of climate?
Can you explain what albinism is and then how you would answer that?
So albinism I guess is basically just climbing big mountains or big snowy or icy
faces or you know,
grant and walls that are also covered with eyes.
I don't know.
I mean albinism is just climbing the things that you see in posters where you're
like,
Whoa,
that looks like a big scary mountain.
You know,
cause I've always been more of a rock climber,
which is climbing like vertical,
dry granite walls.
Um,
albinism is like when you do that and more remote places and like you hike
across a glacier,
you get to the bottom of some huge icy face and then you do all kinds of
shenanigans to get at the top.
So what,
uh,
what mistakes did you make if anyone first starting that type of climbing a
well,
so basically,
I mean,
I haven't done a lot of albinism and I still,
I can't ice climb at all.
I've never led a pitch advice,
but I've actually done a handful of things that are considered like no worthy
alpine a sense now,
but it has more to do with choosing the right partners because I go with
somebody who's like way more experienced than me or just someone who has much
more of a plan.
And then it's sort of about the division of labor,
you know,
like someone who's good at one thing.
And then I'm,
I'm obviously good at the rock climbing component of it.
So even though I'm a total beginner with the ice climbing,
with all the logistics and the camping and like dealing with living on a
glacier,
all that kind of stuff is totally new to me.
But at least I know how to do the climbing pretty well.
So then you know,
you just find the teammate who complements that skillset.
Well,
and then you can go out and climb all kinds of crazy things.
So no,
I probably mentioned this,
the intro,
but just in case I,
for people listening,
I'm sitting in my living room,
we're sitting in my living room and we have a whole like Phalynx of people
surrounding us because we're filming this now.
One of the,
one of the people here has actually been on the podcast before,
said Jimmy Chen.
How does your climbing differ most from his?
Which UV Chan is predominantly a photographer.
So his climbing,
it's not really climbing.
It's mostly just going up behind people take pictures.
I'm talking to you,
Jimmy.
Jimmy's been,
Jimmy's been classically more of a big wall climber.
Um,
I mean,
Jimmy's never been like the best free Clinton.
Like,
you know,
I mean he's not doing one arm pull ups and small edges and he's not like
climbing the hardest sport routes,
but he's always been able to like get to the top of big walls and then had been
able to do that in the mountains,
you know,
with ice and snow and bad conditions.
And so he sort of,
the climate that he's been good at has been like farther along the spectrum of,
you know,
big and Badass.
Then the type of climate,
you know,
cause I grew up in a climbing gym,
um,
and then sort of gradually extended to like big rock walls,
you know,
and he sort of started on big rock walls and then extended into the bigger
mountains.
Who were,
when you were getting started,
just thinking back to say the first 10 years of climbing,
how old,
you know,
I'm 30,
30 getting old and I got that.
I heard your joints creaking.
I feel like.
Who were some of your early mentors in climate?
Um,
I didn't have a lot of mentors when,
I mean I kind of just grew up in the gym just climbing a lot.
So I didn't really have mentors.
I mean I definitely had people that I looked up to and people in the climbing
community,
but that's just sort of the typical hero where should be style.
You know,
like Peter Croft was a really prominent solos from the generation before me and
I was like,
oh,
Peter's the man.
And um,
you know,
Chris Sharma,
obviously it was,
was like setting all kinds of world record type things when I was a kid and I
was just like,
oh,
he's so amazing.
And Tommy Caldwell was also a big hero.
Um,
which has been cool because now I get to climb with Tommy as an adult and I'm
just like,
oh,
that's pretty cool.
Or I'm still always excited to come with me.
But what if you were,
so I'm going to take like 20 different questions and hopefully rapid into one
question and we can,
we can take some time on this,
but if you were taking a,
let's just say an athletic wrote beginner,
so someone who's never done any climbing but it has a decent athletic
background,
right?
20,
25 years old and they want to get really good at say bouldering,
uh,
and you are going to kind of lay out,
give them advice or train them for like eight weeks,
what would you,
what would have them to do?
What would,
what would the,
what would that look like?
I don't know.
I'd have to think about it a lot because I mean,
particularly with bowling,
it's sort of,
it's interesting.
So the adults are more prone to injury then,
then kids to some extent.
And especially with,
with something like bouldering where,
um,
it's really heavy on finger.
Like basically it's really easy to injure your fingers and hands because all the
connective tissue and tendons and ligaments take it very,
very long time to strengthen.
So,
I mean,
there's no real shortcut to,
to avoiding tendon injury,
whereas an adult like a 25 year old male would gain muscle mass super fast.
So really quickly,
they could exceed the capacity of their tenants then basically just rip their
tenants out of their arms,
you know?
And so it's like one of those things where,
I mean if I was trying to train somebody to be a good rock climber,
I would focus on,
on movement and technique and footwork and all those kinds of things.
But if somebody was like,
in eight weeks,
I have to be able to boulder,
like a certain difficulty level,
I'd be like,
well,
I mean,
just start like training your fingers and hope that you don't get injured.
But like,
obviously that's not a sustainable,
like if you're trying to be a good climber,
that's not the way to do it.
It's better to start with like the foundation.
So if let's talk about the,
the footwork and technique then,
because I've,
I mean,
you've been to a ton of climbing gyms.
I've been to mission clutch.
I'm not a good climber.
I would not say,
uh,
but I can also recognize but not dissect when I see good climate versus bad
climate.
Right.
Where people are just,
I'm shaking like a leaf and using a hall arm strength.
Uh,
what,
what types of advice would you give someone who wanted to do it the right way,
but they're like,
all right,
I just,
I want to focus on the right things.
What should I really focus on?
And I would say the right things are our movement and technique.
And so like how you move over the rock has nothing to do with how well you can
hold on or like how hard you pull as to do with,
you know,
knowing where your center of mass is and like being able to move your body
around in the right ways that you can stay balanced over your feet and you can
move yourself upward with your feet.
How do you conserve energy when you're climbing it?
Leaving out the pizza sized pizza box?
Um,
no,
I mean the main ways to save energy or to keep,
keep your weight on your feet,
which is kind of the same thing,
to stay balanced over your feet so that all as much weight as possible as on
your feet.
So you're just standing.
And then to keep your arms straight or to keep all your limbs straight so that
you're hanging off your skeleton more than your muscles.
Because if you have your arms bent at 90 degrees,
like a t rex or something,
then you're like totally engage your bicep and your lats and you're getting
tired.
If you have your arms totally straight,
then you're only engaging just as much muscle as you need to keep your fingers
holding on.
But everything else is relaxed because you're hanging off your bones.
So I want to underscore something you said a little earlier because uh,
a lot of sort of aggressive dudes listened to this podcast is aggressive dude,
aggressive,
like slap on a ton of muscle in my arms and like biceps and lats and go crush
this bouldering wall.
But you made a really important point,
uh,
several,
one of which was that if you,
if you pack on a lot of muscular strength you can outstrip your sort of tendon
and just really quickly what particularly as an adult,
I mean if you start climbing as a kid then then you gain muscle at the sort of
the same.
That's why you're in like hormonal nirvana as an adolescent and this is
something that also a guy named Chris summer coach,
summer underscored for me.
He's the former national a gymnastics team coach for men's and he was saying
that unlike many other
sports like its contra indicated to say use anabolics in gymnastics because all
you're going to do is end up rob rupturing a tendon or ligament for the same
reasons.
Yeah,
totally.
Sounds calming.
Uh,
what do you worry about when you go to sleep at night,
if anything?
Like when you worry before you go to bed,
what kind of stuff do you worry about it I was like that's a quick 80.
Yeah,
this is going to be full of all sorts of weird 90 degree turn to keep listeners
on their toes so that people scrubbing through the podcasts get confused.
I don't want any storyline that they try to skip ahead.
Yeah.
With,
um,
uh,
no,
I don't really worry that much when I,
when I was sleep.
I mean the stuff that I get stressed about is all like real life stuff with,
uh,
you know,
dealing with email and responding to calls and like,
hustling and I don't know,
like doing my taxes,
you know,
like all this stuff that I'm just like not good at.
So let,
let me ask,
this is like partially me turning this into a therapy session for myself here,
but should I just lay down,
lay on the sofa here?
Uh,
that's usually my second day podcast.
The pressure at the just relaxed,
but the,
uh,
the,
the question I'd like to ask is why do this,
when is enough enough to fuel the climbing?
Meaning,
what do you hope to do with the additional money you make above and beyond what
you need to sustain climbing often?
Because it's not that at a certain point you surpass that pretty easily,
but you're certainly keeping busy.
Uh,
your,
you have a number of sponsors,
uh,
you're tremendously good at what you do.
So what do you mean?
I mean,
that is interesting because a,
and I've,
you know,
I've thought about this a lot over the years because for say the first five or
seven years that I was living in the van,
my overhead is probably 10 to 15 k year.
And I now obviously make a lot more than that through sponsorship and just doing
like one commercial or something,
you know,
I can make many times what I need to live in the road for a long time.
And so,
you know,
part of that,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm obviously saving for retirement,
things like that,
trying to be responsible with money.
But,
um,
and then I've also started a foundation where I've been given probably a third
of my income now to,
to a environmental nonprofit things.
Um,
but yeah,
basically,
I mean honestly the foundation was kind of my,
my response to that kind of stuff cause I was like,
I just don't need to make more.
But the thing is it is actually kind of fun to make more,
you know,
it's like fun to do the random opportunities like to do a commercial project or
to like give some talk to some interesting company or you know,
whatever.
I mean it's kind of fun to be able to hustle up money like that,
but then it's like equally fun to be able to use that money for something
positive,
which is through the foundation basically.
What is the name of the foundation?
It,
it's just the Arnold Foundation.
Easy to remember.
Yeah.
It's like kind of Douchey,
but like it kind of made sense.
No,
I don't think it's Douchey.
I think it's easy to remember it.
Just sensible.
Uh,
so the reason I was asking about the,
what do you worry about before you go to bed is because there are people,
I have never seen so many questions about brass balls in my life when I pulled
my readers for questions for you.
And we've never had an in depth conversation.
Uh,
but I know a lot of people say here in Silicon Valley or other folks who give
the appearance of being invincible,
they've,
they never worry about anything.
Uh,
and it can be kind of demoralizing for people who feel like they need to be
superhuman to achieve good things.
And so what I always like to ask people who are spectacular,
good at what they do or dig into is like what challenges they've had or what
they struggle with.
So for those people who say like,
that guy's got everything together,
he doesn't worry about anything.
I'm not like that.
What are some that,
like what,
what are some of the challenges or,
um,
dark periods that you've had,
if any come to mind?
And if the answer is none,
and that's,
that's it.
Financial term.
Vincible no,
I mean,
um,
well it's funny you ask me,
just in the last two months I've had to sort of random injuries that are like
super annoying,
um,
which I hadn't really had any kind of injuries climbing and in years or like
ever really.
Um,
but like last month in April,
I got a,
I got dropped on a partner,
so I got a load off the end of her rope and like compression fracture,
two vertebrae in my back and I was an ultra bruised.
And so my hips and and stuff,
you know,
my back's been really tight.
I've been kind of Achy.
Um,
that worked out kind of.
Okay.
It was two days before I was supposed to fly to China for a climbing expedition.
And,
um,
and so I was like,
well,
all the travel time will sort of be like good rest I guess.
And then,
you know,
I got there and I was like,
creaky old man.
But I actually did manage to climb the thing that we were hoping to do and it
all kind of worked out okay in the end.
But you know,
there was definitely,
it was a little touch and go because I was like,
at first,
I mean when I was going to the airport to fly to China,
I couldn't even lift my duffle bags cause like my back was to soar and
everything was too to creaky.
Um,
and then actually just like two days ago,
I took a weird fall.
Well actually I took a totally normal fall,
but I sound how tweaked my hand in a weird way.
And I'm actually,
I mean you can probably see the back of my right.
Yeah,
I was looking at that.
Yeah.
My right hand,
it's like all messed up right now.
And um,
and you know,
I mean there's definitely a lot of uncertainty there cause I mean,
I can't even like click the power button on my phone without like pretty serious
pain with my right hand right now.
But you know,
it's been two days and it's kind of improving and you know,
we'll see like,
and the things,
the forecast is rain for the next three days.
I'm like,
well,
I'll have three days to rest and then you know,
maybe it will be okay or,
or maybe it will be good enough that I can at least work towards some of my
other goals for the season.
And then by the time it's recovered and say another two weeks I'll be like ready
to,
you know,
do some of the things I'm going to do.
I mean,
we'll see.
We just kind of how China when I was like,
well,
you know,
I can at least do all the work towards what I'm trying to climb while I'm
crippled.
And then by the time it was ready,
by the time I was ready to,
to actually try to climb the route and it was like,
Oh,
well I'm actually feeling good enough by now and I was able to do that.
Do you ever get depressed or have you ever been depressed?
Yeah,
no,
I think,
I mean I think I kind of gravitate towards being a somewhat depressed person.
I don't know.
Or,
I dunno actually,
or I'm just sort of like flat what will stick into that first part and we'll see
what we come up with.
So why do you say that you think?
I definitely,
um,
oscillate to fairly high highs and reasonably low lows and I've been trying to
take the edge,
like take the 20 top like the top and bottom 20% off of those to make it a
little more manageable.
But uh,
why do you say that you might tend towards easy?
I feel like I don't have any of the highs and I kind of go from,
from level to like slightly below level tobacco,
you know,
it's all like,
it's all pretty flat I feel like.
And does that,
when you,
when you dip,
does that,
is that triggered by certain types of things or is it just a cycle that comes
with time?
Um,
I don't know.
Yeah,
maybe it's just a cycle time.
It's like sometimes you just feel useless,
you know?
But I mean in some ways though,
I embrace that as part of the process because you kind of have to feel like a
worthless piece of poop in order to get motivated enough to go do something that
makes you feel less useless.
But then,
but then ultimately that still doesn't make you feel any less useless and you
just have to keep doing more.
So that's perfect segue to the,
uh,
the,
the main question from the,
from the person who asked what you do when you have to take a shit on the side
of a wall.
Is there,
or do you ever see a point where you'll feel that you've accomplished all that
you can in climbing?
Where's,
is there always a,
what's next?
Um,
I think there's definitely,
you know,
I can definitely see a point
where I wouldn't continue pushing.
I mean there is always a,
what's next in climbing and um,
you know,
I mean you can always try to improve in some way or like go to new places or do
first ascents or,
I mean,
you know,
there is always something new to be done in climbing though I can definitely see
personally a point at which,
you know,
I'm like,
okay,
I'm satisfied.
Like I've done more I need to do.
And um,
you know,
yeah,
we'll see you kinda though I will say climbing more than most other professional
sports has like quite a long career span kind of because of that because there's
always more you can do with like trips and expeditions and first versus Sansom
and there's a really creative process to it.
You can always like come up with interesting challenges and it's just sort of
like do things that nobody's thought of before.
And so,
you know,
I mean,
they're professional climbers in their 50s that are still like getting after it
like that.
When,
uh,
when you are about to do a big climb or just a very strenuous,
climbing workout,
I'm not even sure if you do that anymore.
Maybe you could talk about it,
but how do you warm up if you do?
Yeah,
I always warm up pretty,
pretty gently and when I can just,
so just,
um,
I mean it depends on where I am.
If I'm in a climbing gym,
um,
then I just warm up on a handful of easy routes and then,
and then start the harder ones later.
Uh,
I mean for the last month and a half,
I've been stretching like every morning and every night because of the back
thing because how tight my hips and everything feel right now.
Um,
so doing some stretching and some like light exercise to sort of warm up and
then,
you know,
when you can't climb,
uh,
let's just say you're,
you're on the road.
What type of exercise do you do?
I mean,
I,
I try to still climb when I'm on the road.
Um,
I mean there's just so many gyms and different places that you can always do
that.
But,
um,
if there's absolutely nothing,
then maybe I'll run or I'll go hiking or it kind of depends on what
opportunities are.
I mean,
I'd rather go mountain biking then than other things or I'd rather go skiing if
that's available.
Um,
but I mean,
as long as I'm getting some kind of actors,
I mean even like stand up paddle boarding or something,
I'm like,
well at least I did something today.
You know,
a lot of recreational climbers deal with,
as we've touched on earlier,
sort of a hand issues,
wrist issues,
elbow issues.
Uh,
I'm,
I mean he saw me when,
when,
when you guys arrived today.
I had myself wrapped up in this stuff called Voodoo floss cause I had,
my elbows are killing me.
Uh,
and how have you seen climbers,
uh,
keep their elbows and joints in good health?
Is there any particular approaches that you think have had a very,
I don't,
I don't think there's like an easy answer to that kind of stuff.
I mean I had some elbow issues for a while now it's like eight or nine years ago
or something,
but I had to sorta like chronic elbow pain on and off for almost a year.
But then eventually it just sort of resolved and I mean I think the best way
with that kind of stuff,
it's sort of prevention,
you know like may maintain antagonist muscles and just sort of like stay well
balanced and everything and just,
and if you start to feel achiness or pain coming on then to you know,
take the appropriate rest or,
or maybe change your training to some extent or basically just not to let it
become a big problem because I feel like all those overuse injuries,
like once their problem,
then it's like really hard to deal with the antagonistic muscles.
Meaning if you're doing a lot of say like Fletcher work kind of gripping that
you're going to use like finger extension and wrist extension and so on.
Yeah.
Though,
I've actually never done the whole extension stuff with,
with hands,
I don't know.
But to me I'm antagonist muscles are more like doing pushups or random or tricep
poles or things to balance out your arms a bit.
Since you do so much polling,
like to be able to do some kind of pushing.
Sometimes
what's in your mind separates a great climber from a good climber and you can
answer that however you want.
Um,
I dunno,
I mean,
yeah,
I don't let it slow.
Okay.
I'll ask it.
I'll ask it differently.
Who impresses you right now as a club?
Um,
just one of,
I'm sure many,
but a kid,
Mark Andre Le Clercq Marcus,
the student of this Canadian guy.
Um,
he's been doing like all kinds of crazy alpine,
so on.
You're just like,
Whoa,
what makes it so crazy?
I Dunno.
It just,
it just like kind of blows my mind a bit.
And it's funny because I actually don't ice climber or Alpine climb at a high
enough level to quite understand what he's doing.
Even like,
cause it's hard for me to probably appreciate just how hard it is.
But then a lot of my friends who do climate a very high level are like,
Whoa,
that's messed up.
And I'm just like,
yeah,
respect.
And for those people who want to see visuals on this stuff,
we'll,
we'll grab some video and uh,
links to the,
one of the interesting things Mark Andre is that,
I don't know if there is video of most of the stuff that we're doing.
Yeah.
I mean it's just going out and doing all this crazy stuff.
Okay.
You're just like,
it's um,
it's pretty full on will I will,
I will attempt a Jimmy,
you know this guy,
you know of them.
What in your mind makes an impressive as a Alpine Alpine to Alpine climber?
I bet Jimmy hasn't even heard any of this stuff he's like recently been doing in
the Rockies.
It's like pretty crazy.
Yeah.
It's like so crazy.
I'll repeat for you guys listening
generation
is that people are considering,
so he's his ears.
So just to try to paraphrase here.
So his commitment level is just next level and he sort of pushing everyone else
to consider things that haven't been done.
Hello?
He's very calm though.
He does have a ton of experience really.
I mean,
you know,
cause he's just done so much of it.
He's been doing like uh,
any for like,
you know.
Yeah.
So the commitment level meaning pushing the envelope is usually predicated on
experience level.
Therefore you see the,
some of the older guys doing it but know
cause they're all like that's messed up on the,
on the uh,
on the danger side,
this is a question from Paul Jones.
So being the first sponsored superstar free soloing,
do you ever have concerns about the influencer you can have on young climbers
who um,
may not put in the mileage and the training to get to a point where they can do
it as safely?
Yeah.
Well so there are two things.
One,
I'm definitely not the first superstar,
whatever cause there are a bunch of European climbers who are well known for so
line who've come before me.
And even in the u s somebody like John Backer was like super well known in the
1970s and he was on all kinds of TV programs.
It might not have been sponsorship in the same way that we have today because
the industry wasn't the same,
but he was definitely on the evening news and all kinds of crazy things for you
so long.
So I'm,
I mean I'm definitely not the first by any means.
And it's interesting because,
you know,
I was obviously a kid who was influenced by that kind of stuff,
but then I've gone through,
you know,
years and years of practice or whatever.
Um,
I kind of feel like soling is a bit,
uh,
and almost like self regulating in a way.
Because the thing is,
is that anybody can watch a video and be like,
I want to do that.
But then as soon as they climb 15 or 20 feet off the ground,
they start to have a very frank discussion with themselves.
Like,
do I really want to do this?
You know,
like it's something that feels very scary.
Cause I mean people have like an overwhelming fear response to the prospect of
falling to their death,
you know?
And so I had an overwhelming fear response just watching videos.
Well,
yeah,
exactly.
I mean that's kind of the thing is that hardly anybody sees that film.
It's like,
oh,
I'm going to go do that.
And then even even if they do,
once they start trying to do it,
I mean it is actually quite difficult to climb these walls so it's not as if
some kid can just like wander up and do that and then,
and even if they are strong enough or like,
you know,
well versed and ethnic climbing to climb a little bit,
then they're also like,
wow,
this is really,
really scary.
I didn't expect it to be this scary and then they just climbed back down.
Um,
so I mean,
you know,
I've thought a little bit about influencing kids and like,
wondering if that's a bad thing.
But in general like you just don't really see copycat things.
Like you see it a lot more in,
in gravity assist at sports or like action sports.
So like kayaking or skiing or something where like anyone can just line up at
the top of a cliff and be like,
I'm going to hook this cliff and I'm going to stick it and it's going to be
sick.
You know?
And then once they sort of commit and start going and it's like they're going
off the cliff one way or another,
you can start the music,
they can't turn it off.
Yeah,
exactly.
But with climbing,
it's like each move that you make upward is like a decision that you're going to
continue going upward.
You have to decide over and over.
Like,
I want to keep going,
I want to keep going.
I want to keep,
at a certain point you're like,
I don't really want to keep going.
Like I think I would go down and then you're just like mobby you know?
And then like,
yeah,
I mean,
have you ever hit that point when it was,
let's just say,
Oh,
we've started screaming for Mommy,
mommy,
a whore,
like hundreds of feet up and you're like,
I don't want to keep doing this.
Yeah,
no,
I've definitely had a bunch of times so long where I'm like,
I'm not into this.
I'm going down.
And what happens then,
because I've,
I've never seen footage of you climbing down,
but that's kind of a practical thing is that if you have people that are filming
with you,
it's like obviously you're doing something that you've rehearsed or,
or a,
you know,
a lot about,
or it's like,
you know,
it's a classic enough root that it's worthy to film on.
Like you have all those epic misadventures on things that like aren't that well
known that,
you know,
people are in climbing all the time.
But no.
So I've had tons of experiences where,
um,
especially when I was younger,
I didn't really know how to read Topo.
Is that,
well,
the little maps that show you like where a climbing route goes.
So I'd look at it and be like,
okay,
I think I'm climbing that big corner.
And then I'd go up there and be like,
this isn't even the right route.
Like,
what the heck am I doing?
And then I'd start like questing way to their left or right being like,
well,
maybe if I traverse 200 feet that way then I'll get to the real root.
And then you're like,
Oh God,
what am I doing?
And then it all starts to go south,
you know?
Uh,
and,
and then you'd climb down in an instant slow,
or I would like quest over to some other route and escape off west donors is
just a traverse.
Yeah.
Or,
or whatever.
You know,
there are many,
a couple routes where I've been like,
especially when I was younger,
when I was holding a route and I get up and all of a sudden I'm like,
Oh,
I'm on a bolted face,
but this route isn't supposed to have bolts.
And then I'm like,
oh no,
I'm on the wrong route.
And then you like look over and you see that the real route you're supposed to
be on,
it's like a hundred meters to the right.
And then you're like,
I wonder what route I'm on.
oh,
I hope it's not hard.
And then you're suddenly like,
Shit.
And then you start like pulling on the bolts,
which is cheating.
Um,
and you're just like,
whatever it takes to like get off this wall,
you know?
And so you're like pulling on bolts and stepping on bolts and like doing
whatever just to like get to the top and then later you're like,
oh,
I wish I knew how to read the guide book.
Uh,
no.
So this is,
this is a related question from drew Cordova.
So there's a video that shows Alix climbing El cap free solo where he said he
was freaking out incorrect.
Well,
there are all kinds of income.
Sure.
There's lots of yeah,
yeah.
Just go on and on where he's freaking out on the cliff face at one point.
I'd like to know from his perspective what it takes to overcome that fear.
Uh,
okay.
So the video clip that he's referring to,
I'm actually free soloing in the face of half dome,
which is a different wall.
Yep.
And that's actually complicated because it shows me standing on this ledge on
half dome,
like having a moment,
being really scared.
But we shot that film like a year after my actual free Solo.
So I had gone up there and saw it about myself,
nobody around,
which is kind of the point of free soloing normally.
And then we'd gone back and filmed on it and when we filmed on it I walked out
on that ledge and like had a moment where I was a little bit afraid and then
like sorted myself out,
turn around and climb back.
But then they use the voiceover of me talking about the original experience when
I've actually been free song at the year before where I had like a much more
significant moment on a section a hundred feet higher,
which is actually quite difficult.
Climbing cause like walking across a ledge is never that scary.
You know what I mean?
Like in the grand scheme of rock climbing,
like when you're standing on the ledge,
like you're not scared.
Um,
it just happened in that case cause I was standing face out,
which is like a little off balance and a little scary.
And I was like,
Whoa,
this isn't what I expected.
But it's not that big a thing,
but the actual experience of higher,
it was like one of those things where they caught this moment on film and it
kind of went well with the voiceover and they're like all perfect.
Yeah,
exactly.
And so it made for a great film and it definitely like shares the free solo
experience pretty well.
It was one of the things at first I was like,
I was sort of annoyed that it's not the literal like this isn't what happened,
but the thing is like nobody's there when it actually happens.
So then it does share the experience pretty well.
So in the actual halftone experience when it was scary,
even though,
like you mentioned earlier,
you've kind of rehearsed what it's gonna feel like as you're going up this,
this route.
What do you,
what do you,
and not to Belabor this point,
but it's,
it's a,
it's something I'm fascinated by.
What's going through your head and how do you,
was that particular halftone Free Solo?
I actually hadn't rehearsed it that much really.
Um,
I'd sort of intentionally chosen not to rehearse the root very much cause I was
like,
oh,
that's going to take the adventure out of it.
I want to just go up there and do it.
Which in retrospect like wasn't the best idea.
But so,
uh,
yeah,
on halftime I didn't,
I hadn't memorized the sequences.
I didn't really know like exactly what I should do.
I just knew that I could do it.
I knew that I'd gone up there and I'd done it.
It was fine.
And that I was able to,
um,
you know,
in retrospect I probably should've spent a little bit more time.
And so why I got so scared was I got up to a certain sequence and I basically
like didn't want to trust a specific foothold.
And I was like,
oh,
this feels like my foot's gonna slip and I don't want to fall.
And then I tried to use some other feet,
but I was like,
oh,
this doesn't,
these are worse.
And you know,
so you're standing there hesitating being like,
what should I do?
What should I do?
And then you start to get all gripped like,
Oh God,
what if I can't figure it out?
And like you're obviously getting more and more tired as you stand there.
Your calves are getting pumped and you know,
yeah,
it's just,
it's traumatizing.
Okay.
Back in action.
So doing a little break,
we were just talking about some past lives and uh,
as mentioned that I wanted to be a comic book.
Penciler was an illustrator for a period of time paying expenses in college and
had this other weird side Gago bouncing,
which was terrible because I was always the smallest guy,
uh,
as a bouncer.
But what are the,
what are the best and worst jobs that you've,
that you had prior to climbing?
I haven't really had that many jobs.
I mean,
I worked at the climbing gym as a kid,
um,
just,
you know,
cleaning the bathrooms and doing summer camp stove with kids.
And then I worked doing night security at Berkeley for first semester that I was
there.
I mean,
I was only at Berkeley for a year and so for my second semester there I was
doing night security.
I was basically,
it's like walking around campus at night,
you're getting paid to like look at buildings.
But
uh,
when you at Berkeley,
how did you decide to leave and what was that calculus like?
I mean,
how long
decide to just drop out of Berkeley?
It was more that I wasn't really happy there.
And then,
um,
my first year at Berkeley I happened to get second at the national at nationals.
And so I got invited to the Youth World Cup,
which was during what would have been my second fall semester.
And so I decided to take the semester off and then go do you know,
youth worlds and then travel a bit and climb and do whatever.
Um,
and also my father happened to die the summer after freshman year and he was
part of the pressure for like going to school and not really pressure,
but he just sort of like expected the kids to go to college type thing.
And then when he died it also left life insurance money for my sister and I had
finished school.
And so,
you know,
that sort of allowed me to not,
she did not go back to school and so,
uh,
yeah.
And so just kind of a combination of events just led me to take the semester off
and then it just like,
you know,
I'm just taking the next 10 or 20 semesters off.
Since then,
were you close to your dad?
Um,
I was fairly close to my dad.
I mean,
or we weren't super close and like talking about things and like having,
having deep chats,
but he definitely infested
a ton of time in me.
You know,
he took me to the climbing gym all the time.
He would drive me all over the state to competitions,
you know,
he would taking camping,
take me outside.
Like,
you know,
we,
we would do be doing family camping trips in the mountains and stuff.
Um,
so I mean,
he definitely put a ton of energy into me
to you.
And I apologize.
I don't know your status.
Do you want to get married?
Have Kids?
Um,
yeah,
I think I'd like to have a family someday.
So that,
that brings up something that I wanted to talk about and the hesitated to ask in
part because I'm sure you've been asked a million times,
but as it relates to mortality,
let's just say that somebody came to you because this is kind of two in one,
uh,
they said I have
$10 million and I'm going to dedicate to you,
but with the following conditions,
you have to predict how you're going to die accurately.
And in that case it goes to the cause of your choosing.
So what would you predict and what caused me to go to,
um,
that's interesting.
And if I predict wrong,
it just like doesn't go into disappears.
Oof.
Um,
okay.
I dunno.
I mean I think I would predict,
I don't know,
I'm sort of 50,
50 between natural causes,
just like dying of old age at some point.
Or like climbing accident in the grander scheme of like,
not necessarily,
um,
you know,
like falling to my death,
which is what people think with a free soloing.
But just the random stuff like,
you know,
repelling in the mountains are like being swept by an avalanche or like being
hit by a random rock because there's a lot of just like random chance or not a
lot,
but there is random chance chance involved with climbing and just the fact that
I am out climbing all the time.
Like it wouldn't be shocking of some random thing just happened to me like that.
Um,
though,
I mean that's kind of the,
the,
you know,
price price to play,
like if you're going to be in those places,
like there is just a random random risk associated with it.
Um,
so yeah,
I mean I think and then the cause I would devote it to,
um,
I dunno,
some probably environment.
I mean basically the stuff that I'm supporting through my foundation,
which is a,
you know,
any kind of environmental project that like improve standard of living,
which has mostly been like off grid solar projects are like energy access and
stuff for off grid solar energy excess for,
for whom or wherever,
like rural communities.
I mean I've been supporting a group that does that kind of work in Africa,
which,
you know,
makes sense cause folks have no access to energy.
And we've also been supporting grid alternatives here in the states,
which does a like home PV systems for like low income families.
Um,
basically it's just a way to like help,
you know,
folks that need some help and it helps the environment obviously.
And
just we took a break.
You were talking about,
we were talking,
talking about books and the fact that you read mostly nonfiction,
uh,
what nonfiction books have had a,
had an impact on you or do you particularly like?
Um,
I mean in the last several years,
I mean,
some of the most noteworthy books I've read,
I guess I'm like a People's history of the u s the Howard Zinn book totally
changed the way I look at politics.
Um,
and then in the same way,
uh,
I read a book recently called sacred economics that totally changed the way I
looked at economics.
Sacred Economics.
Yeah.
It was actually totally understand.
I forget who the author was now though.
I didn't know.
I will,
we will look it up and you should,
you should have shown a sacred economics was like kind of awesome.
It like,
yeah,
it changed my world event.
But uh,
what's,
what are the,
what's this kind of basic thesis of sacred economics or is it,
um,
I don't know what the author would say pieces,
but um,
but the things that I took away from it,
we're,
well,
I mean basically he sort of envisioning different systems for like a more just
kind of economics,
you know?
Cause I mean current,
our current style of capitalism basically just concentrates wealth in the hands
of the already wealthy,
you know,
I'm in,
that's kind of like by definition,
the way interest rates work and stuff.
Like if you have a lot,
you'll just continue to make a lot.
And that's not a fundamentally fair system because if you don't have anything,
you continue nothing.
But if you already have more than you need,
you just get more and more and more.
And that's just not the way the world should work,
I don't think.
Or at least I don't,
I don't know.
So one of the ideas that he throws out in the book,
which I found totally understand was like negative interest rates.
So like,
um,
if you have a lot,
it basically just like slowly dwindles away unless you're actively using it for
things like investing it into things.
So,
you know,
just by having a lot of money is not going to guarantee that you continue to
have a lot of money unless you're allocating it in.
Exactly.
Unless you're using it wisely to like create value.
But how do you assess risk,
whether that's with a,
and you can,
you can focus on one of these,
but whether that's on a particular climb on like a business venture,
a decision to do a versus B,
how do you,
how do you think about risk?
Uh,
Eh,
I don't know.
That's an interesting question because obviously I spent a ton of time thinking
about risk,
but I just don't have like a clear cut,
you know,
like I don't have clear metrics for like,
Oh,
you know,
this is because with the climbing,
so much of it comes down to a feeling of like I feel a lot of fear when I think
about that.
Obviously it's not for me.
Um,
but yeah,
I don't,
I don't know exactly and I've never really had to evaluate business ventures and
things.
So when I,
so let's touch on something you just said,
which is if you're very afraid of something,
then that's something you shouldn't do.
So do you then climb,
say hard routes in an absence of fear or is it present and then you overcome it?
That's a good question.
Um,
I genuinely climb hard roots in the absence of fear.
I generally don't go up on them unless I feel comfortable and I don't have that
fear.
Yes,
though.
Yeah.
Though,
I mean,
it's important to sort of differentiate fear and risk and like all the terms I
guess.
Definitely because,
um,
you know,
I mean if there is a high level of risk,
I mean you should be feeling fear.
I mean fear is sort of that warning that you know,
like that there is real danger.
And so like if there is danger president,
like I mean you should be feeling fear and so,
you know,
and there are times and maybe you should just suppress that fear and go for it
anyway.
Maybe not,
I don't know.
But so with the free soloing,
typically if I'm feeling a lot of fear then um,
I just,
you know,
wait and prepare more or I don't know,
some do whatever it takes to mitigate that,
to like to feel comfortable and then,
and then do the cloud.
When I feel comfortable in,
do you have a,
my,
my suspicion says no,
but do you have eight a checklist?
Like,
I have to do this with gear x number of times and then do this y number of times
before I'm willing to free solo this or is it just don't have a checklist.
But I definitely have a degree of comfort that I need to feel on the route
before I'm willing to solid.
What does that feel like?
It just feels like a certain,
I guess I need to have a certain amount of reserve,
I guess.
You know,
I,
I need to feel like I can climb the route in a variety of conditions,
um,
and,
and have some extra in the tank just in case,
you know,
like if I can climb the route only by the narrowest of like razor thin margins.
Like,
I mean that's probably not good enough for free soloing.
And,
uh,
the definitions point is important.
So for instance,
I'm involved with a lot of speculative startups or startups,
whether spec specter all speculative,
but most of them would be considered very highly speculative.
And people say,
wow,
that's a really high risk investment.
You have a very high risk tolerance,
right?
Doing things in entrepreneurship and so on.
And I've never felt that way.
I actually feel like I'm focused on risk mitigation at all times.
Uh,
and uh,
so for me I thought about it at one point cause they're like,
oh,
you have really high risk tolerance,
risk,
risk risk.
And I was like,
well wait a second.
Like we should try to figure out the definition of this term that we're using
before we have a discussion then it isn't,
the thing that started
this is that you're sort of willing to lose money on a certain number as long as
the,
exactly.
So I'm come out.
Right,
exactly.
So I assume you're sort of just doing the math on the overall picture.
It's like it doesn't matter if some of them fail.
That's exactly right.
And what what's important at least in that game right is or that sport,
and you can look at it that way,
is following your own rules.
Like if you set rules and you understand say portfolio theory and the math if I
follow these rules,
is going to,
is going to turn out likely this way,
therefore I need to make x number investments.
Yeah.
Or at least having like a plan that you're willing to stick to and not,
and then not start to just go hog wild where you're like,
well,
this guy said that
and you're like,
DVM.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
so what I realized for myself that risk in my mind is the likelihood of an
irreversible negative outcome.
And if I look at it that way,
if I do something that fails,
if I can get back to where I was very easily,
then that's not a risk.
It's not a high risk.
For instance.
Do you,
uh,
do you think you relate to risk or think about it differently than other people?
Um,
no,
I mean all of that.
It's pretty much in line with the way I look at risk.
I mean,
yeah,
I mean with the startup stuff,
I wouldn't consider it up particularly risky because like,
obviously people make a lot of money off startups.
It's just a matter of like doing it well and like,
you know,
playing the stock market and things like that.
People obviously make a lot of money,
so it's not like a fundamentally risky activity.
It's just a matter of like how you do it,
how well you do it.
And obviously I'm not in either of those worlds.
That also,
I mean for me it probably would be dangerous because you know,
I'd be like,
well no I have no money,
but it's because that's not my thing.
Like I don't,
I don't know anything about it.
What is the best decision you've ever made?
Not to do something or a good decision that you've made not to do something?
Well,
I think pretty much any of the free solos that are backed off of and climbed
down,
we're probably all pretty good decisions.
I mean,
who's to say,
I mean maybe they all would have been fine and I would've just like climb to the
top and have a nice day.
But you know,
there's no point in second guys and that stuff.
I mean,
if you're not psyched you,
and I was like,
uh,
but I haven't had any like clear or like near misses where I decided not to
climb something.
And then there's like a huge avalanche.
The sweeps the whole mountain and you're like,
thank God I wasn't up there.
Uh,
you have very minimalist lifestyle.
what is,
what is something that you spent too much but don't regret
or something that you spend too much on but don't regret or a lot on too much is
too judgemental.
Um,
I,
I dunno,
I don't think it's too much,
but um,
when I bought noise canceling headphones,
I was like,
this seems really indulgent,
but it made my life so much better.
Like I love traveling with noise canceling headphones.
It's like my favorite possession of thing.
How do you use them?
I just saw me,
I cancel noise with them.
Do you use them all the time when you're traveling or are they sending the
airport and on the plane?
I pretty much have noise canceling headphones on the whole time.
I love it.
I'll just like listen to soft music and like read my book or working on my
computer,
do whatever,
you know,
just hang out.
But I just like love not having all the crazy bustly noise around me the whole
time.
What type of music do you listen to?
Most often when you're flying?
I'm flying,
I do a lot of soundtracks,
like so it's sorta like classically type music but you know,
set to Indiana job but say or whatever.
And brave heart.
Actually I've never done the papers out drag but like last Mohicans as a
favorite.
That's a great contract.
Yeah.
Uh,
do you ever climb to music?
Um,
I'll do easy climbing to music for sure.
I normally just have my phone in my pocket and we'll just blast it like,
you know,
stereo style.
Um,
but that's only if I'm climbing something where there's nobody around.
And cause I think it's super annoying when you hike up to people on a trail,
like a boombox going,
cause obviously it's like dementia in their outdoor experience.
What do you,
in this cases,
what type of music do you listen to?
Um,
I pretty much only listened to like modern rock,
like hate rock and stuff.
Like what I said,
but like what can,
what can events,
oh,
I dunno.
Like I was listening to like bad religion.
We listened botanical as not in the drive and like,
you know,
I'm not sure bell or tool or random whatever.
What is something that people,
and this is in in quotes know about you that is wrong?
I don't know.
I mean I think a lot of people,
I mean certainly online commentary,
a lot of people think I have a death wish or like have never experienced fear.
Like just don't,
don't care about my safety.
I mean the thing is that if you just watched youtube videos,
you get the impression that I just like walk up to a wall and climate and like
you sort of miss the 20 years of climbing culture that's behind it.
You know,
the fact that I've,
that there's a huge history behind all these routes and I know a lot about,
I'm going,
I have tons of friends that have climbed them and I can,
I could like recite half the moves on them from memory.
You know what I mean?
Like there's a ton that goes into other people like don't see you in a three
minute youtube short and yeah,
well it's to like head Laird Hamilton on the podcast,
right?
The sort of undisputed King of Big Wave Surfing people would,
it's funny how people look at that and they have a different judgment than when
they look at you on a wall.
Even though in practical terms you think having,
don't people look at his big wave surfing and be like,
that guy's crazy.
He has a death wish.
Well,
cause I kind of do.
I'm like that.
So it looks like,
so I think that it's slightly the degree,
the frequency with which p I hear people say that it's different because they
look at a wall and they're like,
oh,
I could climb up things,
but they look at eight the hundred foot wave and
somebody's getting towed in on a jet ski and they're like,
I wouldn't even be able to stand up on the board while getting pulled on Jetski
therefore assumption,
assumption,
assumption.
Uh,
what do you think of say a free divers who tried to break records in free
diving?
I mean,
I,
I don't know much about it,
but it does seem like it's one of the riskiest sports in the world.
I mean,
more people die doing that then virtually anything else?
Yeah,
I mean it kind of goes with the wing suiting or something where like,
you know,
it's fair to say that it actually is quite risky because people do actually die
all the time doing it.
Have you ever done any wingsuit stuff?
Um,
no.
I did my iff,
so I learned how to,
to parachute out of a plane,
um,
on the thought that I would maybe eventually learn how to base jump or
something.
And then I was basically just like,
I'm not into this.
I'm like,
I don't think this is cool.
I don't like it.
Just the,
just because the risk,
the downside risk.
No,
I mean,
outside of,
um,
no,
a skydiving,
it was not dangerous,
you know?
So I mean,
when you're learning out of the plane,
like it's not sketchy at all.
But mostly I was like,
I just don't like this,
you know?
And like,
I don't want to devote the energy to like learning how to do this.
And I sort of realized how much it would take for me to,
to feel comfortable doing that.
And I was like,
this is just dom,
I'm not into it.
Yeah.
And then as it turns out,
um,
you know,
like one of my good friends and climbing partners died wing suiting and then
last year a notably dean potter died wing suiting.
And so I mean,
you know,
climbing has lost a lot of high end climbers to wing suiting accidents.
It's like,
yeah,
I mean it is a very dangerous activity.
Uh,
image and dean potter.
Do you slow the,
I mean I think when I hear his name,
uh,
I also associated with sidelining.
Exactly.
Slap biting.
You seem to have the perfect slacklining feet.
I'd,
I mean maybe we take a photograph there new most of,
yeah,
you got some amazing like functional feet.
Do you slack lines?
That's a very kind way,
but it deformed highly functional.
Yes.
Do you slack?
Do you slack line or what's your opinion?
Mine like a low level,
you know,
I can like walk the lines back and forth just because there's so many slack
lines in campgrounds and climbing areas and things.
You know,
I definitely have done a fair amount of slacklining and I can do some like
really easy tricks and things.
But,
but no,
I'm definitely not a sock liner and I've never done any high lines and I'm not
like,
I'm not in the slacklining.
When you think of the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind for you?
When I hear successful?
Yeah,
just the word successful.
I mean when you just set it up Elon Musk,
but that like,
I have no idea,
you know,
like,
cause I don't know,
but I don't know that much about business,
but I'm just like,
that's Rad.
But is there a,
is there anyone that you would want to model your life after in any way?
Um,
probably not,
but do I do like reading a biography or something and then sort of like,
I have some notes on my phone of like lists from random things I've read,
you know,
where you sort of choose it,
a lessons out of like a book about somebody and you're like,
oh,
like that person did these things well,
and those are all things that I could apply to my life.
But,
you know,
I wouldn't want to model my whole life.
I'm somebody.
It's more like,
you know,
Cherry picker and a good lesson
here and there,
which biographies have produced a lot of notes for you.
We'll just do this a few times.
But,
so I read the biography of a Brad Washburn who was like a big deal if you know
him.
He was like,
I don't wanna ask explorer photographer.
He also ran the,
like a natural history museum and in Boston I think.
Um,
but so he just had like a wide and varied career and he was like a national
geographic explorer type.
You know,
he just did a lot with his life.
And so after I finished reading the book,
I was like,
Whoa,
this kind of like got shit done,
you know?
And I don't know,
you know,
I respect that.
And so I just like Kinda thought about it.
What is something that you believe that other people think is crazy?
That I believe that other people think is crazy.
Why don't,
I mean,
I think that my evaluation of risk and all of the things we were just talking
about a lot of people think is totally crazy.
Um,
but that speaking,
I mean,
I think it's because they don't have a full set of facts on it.
You know,
that they don't quite appreciate it in the same way that I do.
But
I don't know if I have any other like totally outlandish beliefs like that.
I know you,
uh,
I'm sure you've had this question before,
but would you consider yourself a religious person give a particular belief
system?
No,
I'm like strongly atheist and just like not into religion at all.
Were your parents religious at all?
Um,
yeah.
Mom has at least used to identify as Catholic as she'd probably still say that
she believes in God though there's no evidence of it at all.
You know,
like she doesn't go to church anymore or do anything.
But um,
yeah.
So as kids we were taking a church,
but at no point did I ever believe anything.
Okay.
So there was no sort of transitionary period?
It was,
no,
I know,
it's funny,
like even though we were being taken to church,
I just always thought it was all a bunch of weird stories.
You're just like,
it made no sense to me.
I'm like,
why would you believe in some invisible thing that,
you know,
I'm like,
why would you ever believe any of that?
Like it doesn't make any sense.
It's weird.
It's weird that so many adults believe all that stuff cause it still doesn't
make any sense.
There's a lot of stuff that doesn't make a lot of sense that people believe to
the theater of politics and all sorts,
you know.
Well,
you know,
but,
uh,
this is going to be a gear shift.
I mean,
where she had a lot of years.
I'm grinding out the transmission of gears,
but,
uh,
food I want to talk about.
Do you have any particular thoughts on food or how do you think about eating
yourself of not literally eating yourself yet?
Uh,
I mean,
I'm not much of a cook and I don't like love food or food prep or anything,
you know,
I mean,
if I could,
I would just like take a pill and be like fully fully fed all day,
every day and just be like,
sweet.
I don't have to do worry about it.
But,
um,
I dunno.
I mean in the last couple years have gone vegetarian,
um,
which has more to do with all,
like the environmental nonfiction I've been reading.
It's more just as like one of the few things that I can do as an individual to
like really have an impact on the world.
Um,
but yeah,
I don't know.
I mean,
do you have any,
uh,
give any goto dinners?
Like what are your most common dinners?
What do they look like?
Um,
I mean for all the years that I've lived in the van,
one of my go to dinners was like Mac and cheese with,
with stuff in it,
you know,
like adding a vegetable,
you stat tuna to it a lot.
Then I've switched to just like vegetables or you know,
maybe some beans or whatever.
You're like Mac and cheese and chili though.
Now I'm sort of easing life from the Mac and cheese too cause I've kind of
stopped eating dairy but so like,
you know,
rice and vegetable stuff or like lentils or whatever.
Keeping it simple.
Yeah.
So many questions.
So many questions I want to ask.
Do you have any morning rituals?
Like what are the first 60 days,
60 days,
the first 60 minutes of your day?
Um,
like pretty much always just get up and have like a big breakfast and then go
climbing.
That's kind of the standard.
When is Zoe will wake up for the last two months I've been waking up and doing
some 15 minutes of stretching,
then eating my breakfast,
then going climbing just because of the back stuff.
But,
um,
what time do you generally wake up and go to bed?
Um,
I generally,
I'm pretty unstructured,
so I basically just go to sleep whenever I'm,
whenever I need to or whenever it makes sense.
Then I just wake up whenever I tried to sleep as much as I want to.
What does that mean?
People think they're like,
oh,
that four hour work week guy.
Like I'm asleep three hours a night.
I tried to sleep eight to 10 maybe.
Yeah.
No,
I'm all about the eight to 10 for sure.
I think last night,
I mean I was sleeping in front of her house last night.
I think I slept nine last night.
Well because the second that the van,
yeah,
that's my walking my dog and I was like,
who's camped out in front of my house?
Yeah.
No,
that is fucking hilarious.
Okay.
Yeah,
we'd like the reflectors in the way.
I was like,
dude,
who is trying to kid that?
Me?
Who is my rape wagon porch in front of your house?
What was,
it's one of the things like,
you know,
we drove to San Francisco
and then I'm like,
well I don't want to park somewhere else and then have to drive here in the
morning.
So I was like,
I'm just going to go park there and went to sleep as late as possible.
I'm going to wake up and I'm going to come in and do a podcast and be like,
totally chill it from,
from what?
That's the thing about living in a car is you're all about minimizing the waste
of time.
You know?
There's no point in like driving around in circles.
You just park where you need to be,
sleep and then do your thing.
That's amazing.
All right,
so the thing is after,
and I've lived in a van for like 10 years now,
you know,
it starts to become routine.
It's like hard to imagine like going to a hotel,
moving all your shit into a room,
moving it back into your car later moving the car.
You're just like,
what a waste of time.
I just want to like park where I need to be.
A lot of people have asked this and I'm kind of curious myself,
like the logistics of Alex Honnold.
So if you have a date date goes well,
what?
Then they come back to the band.
I mean he's a nice man.
It's like a,
you call it a little mini home or whatever,
you know,
want a micro home stuff or what's it called?
The tails.
Yeah.
Tiny town with a bunch of tiny home books rather than go see I have one off
front.
Sit down before you go out on the day.
Do you like just in case this goes well,
do you put out like,
like,
like some rose petals in a bowl of water or like no preference profit.
We'd go back to their place,
middle class here.
Uh,
do you have any favorite documentaries or movies?
Um,
I dunno.
Not Particularly,
I guess.
Um,
I mean,
my movie tastes runs who are just straight like a Hollywood action movie,
like total fluff,
you know,
like gladiator or something.
Just like fun times.
Like,
yeah.
Roger.
All right,
well we'll keep,
we'll keep that.
It's all pretty.
Yeah,
it's all just pretty like unimpressive.
But it's a kind of,
because like movies,
cause I do a lot of like reading nonfiction and stuff.
I feel like movies fill the fluff category,
you know,
like I hate heavy nonfiction or like heavy documentary type films.
I'd just like fall asleep to,
there's too much thinking after all the intersection,
what movies have you seen the greatest number of times?
Is there anything you've watched like over and over again?
I have that habit.
Um,
I've probably seen the star wars movies a lot,
a lot of times,
but that's partially just because I started running as a kid and then I'm like
rewash them over the years.
Um,
I dunno if I've seen anything else.
Like more than that probably.
I think I have maybe weird numbers because for each of my books I get very,
I feel very isolated if I'm writing at night in a dark house by myself.
So I always put it on certain movies,
movies for each book.
They're usually one or two movies that I'll just put on repeat and I'll put them
on me that and then listen to music like the same tracks over and over and over
and over again.
Just brain might be like hardwired in some weird ways here.
That's definitely true.
Tweaking the same recommendation from this.
Uh,
very,
very uh,
brilliant and capable entrepreneur named Matt Mullenweg who's of great coder and
he always,
he listens to the same single track over and over again,
almost like a noise machine when he's coding.
And I thought,
okay,
well I'll try that with writing.
And it worked really,
really well.
But the Moody's end up being really weird because yes it will movies we were
taught so well for the four hour work week.
It was the,
this isn't that weird.
I think these are fine movies,
but the Bourne identity was the first and then for the four body it was casino
rail,
which I think is fantastic.
And you're going to say like rocky or something,
like it'd be a nonstop training montage was while we were there,
a lot of fight scenes and the park core sequence in the beginning,
uh,
with Sebastien.
Incredible.
That's,
yeah,
that's,
that's a whole separate,
I didn't know.
Oh,
oh yeah.
So that's cool.
And then for the four hour chef,
this is super,
this is off theme completely,
but I was just looking for a movie when I was just getting started and on Amazon
Prime,
the first movie that popped up was babe,
a little pig farmer hogget pigment like a thousand times because I just put it
on repeat and watch it like four or five times a night.
Whoa.
Go figure.
Yeah,
we could psychoanalyze that.
Uh,
hardcore hardcore.
Aside from the noise canceling headphones,
what purchase has most positively impacted your life in the last,
say,
six months?
Definitely my van.
Definitely your man.
I mean,
no question.
Yeah,
I mean,
the last fan that,
uh,
you know,
I bought a $10,000 and lived in it for 10 years and then,
uh,
this new van that I bought,
it's the new van.
So it's obviously a bit pricier,
but it's like pretty awesome.
I'll probably live in there for another 10 years.
Well,
maybe not actually live in it,
but you know,
it'd be based out of it.
Uh,
again,
returning to the,
uh,
this is,
this is not directly related to the dating and the van,
but this is,
this is a question from Michael Supriano.
Uh,
I've always found climbing to have a large positive effect on my libido.
Do you,
does Alex find this to be the case?
Well,
I've climbed for my entire life.
So I mean,
maybe it explains to the permanent and this
is that for real?
That's a real like question I guess.
I don't know.
But I mean that's probably true of anybody who's like staying active and staying
fit and you know,
you know,
you're just like,
it's the way your body's supposed to work.
Yeah.
Are there
ways that you've seen lessons learned or skills developed and climbing translate
to other parts of your life?
And if so,
does any edge or any particular examples come to mind?
Um,
I don't know exactly.
I mean,
so I've gained a lot from being a professional climber,
like having to go and give talks and like do the whole work site of climbing.
I mean that's really like helped me grow as a person and feel comfortable doing
public speaking and all that kind of stuff.
Though I think from the actual climbing itself,
maybe the most useful thing I've gotten has been sort of being able to
differentiate,
you know,
risk and consequence and fear and like all these different things and sort of
being able to separate my feelings from what's actually happening.
You know,
like oh I feel fear.
But is that fear justified because I'm actually in danger or is that like
totally irrational fear that I should just squish and like move forward with
something and I don't,
I don't know.
I mean,
I feel like climbing has sort of helped me understand like the different things
that are going on there,
you know?
Whereas I feel like a lot of people are just like,
oh,
I'm afraid.
And then they're just like,
Oh God,
I'm afraid.
You know?
But sometimes like,
I mean,
fear shouldn't necessarily control you any more than anything else,
you know,
desire or fill in the blank.
You know,
when you're really hungry,
you're not like,
Oh God,
I'm hungry,
I'm hungry.
You're just like,
oh,
I'll eat lunch in two hours.
You know?
And I feel like fear to some extent it should be the same way where you can just
register it like,
oh,
I'm feeling fear right now.
But sometimes that doesn't matter.
I mean,
sometimes it does and you need to be like,
oh,
you know,
I'm about to die.
Like I should watch out for that.
But,
but a lot of times,
I mean,
you should be able to just set that fear aside and just do exactly what you're
supposed to be doing.
Yeah.
So I mean,
in a way,
when you're a connoisseur of fear,
I mean you can,
you can distinguish sort of the varietals.
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
When you experienced enough fear in your life,
you're like,
no.
And now I can sort of differentiate between all the different types.
Do you drink coffee or caffeine?
No though I don't have,
I just don't like coffee.
Um,
and I don't really like tea and,
but I don't have any problem with caffeine.
I don't really even notice caffeine.
I don't think that much cause you get it in like shot blocks and gels and goos
and whatever.
All the little energy products,
like some of them have caffeine and some don't.
And I don't feel like I notice an effect either way.
Well the reason I asked is that I personally,
I remember I did a three day meditation retreat,
my first meditation retreat and they disallowed caffeine.
I said no caffeine and no alarm clocks.
You wake up when you wake up.
And when I came in my life was 20 year meditation.
Yeah I need to do more of that.
And I came back from that experience and went back into my normal routine,
which was drinking,
not coffee at that point,
but a lot of ice tea.
Like I'd go to a restaurant and they would just endlessly refill my state.
And I felt like a complete crack head,
like a miserable crack.
And I was like,
is this what my normal was?
Holy Shit.
And the reason that I brought it up is that it strikes me that at least in that
state,
I would have a lot of trouble distinguishing the fine nuances of different
types of things.
Cause you're just overwhelming.
You're all jacked up on sugar from IC stuff and then you're like caffeine and
who knows.
Yeah,
totally.
There's like a lot going on physiologically and it's hard to differentiate like
what the,
what the finer points are.
Yeah.
The signal from the noise
at what climbing grades have you plateaued the most?
This is from Liz Wolfe and she's,
she just said five 11 plateau has been really bad for me,
which probably means she hasn't got past the five.
Let me blessed.
She's just like mired in five 11,
nine.
Um,
no.
So I've basically,
I pretty much progressed steadily to about mid five,
14.
It's like 14 BRC and I've basically been plateaued there for like seven or 10
years or something.
Um,
though I feel like I've sort of Plateau there because I'm at the point.
I mean cause mid five 14 is definitely a fairly high level of climbing though.
It's by no means elite by the world standard anymore.
Like that's not,
that's not like super hard.
Just to put it in perspective what it,
what would be the hardest thing in the world is 15 c but only two people have
climbed that.
But there are a lot of people climbing like 15 [inaudible] and 15 [inaudible]
now.
And so climbing like 14 B or c is like,
you know,
respectable.
But a lot of people can do that.
Like first try,
no PR,
not a lot,
but a handful of people can climb that first try.
No problem.
It's like trivial for them.
So you know what I mean?
It's not,
it's by no means world standard,
but you know,
it's,
it's solid.
But so I think that for me that's sort of my natural plateau.
Like that's kind of what I can climb without having to train much to climb
harder.
You know,
because the thing is I spend a lot of my year doing like adventure trips and
expeditions and you know,
doing stuff through my foundation and going to ankle last year.
I mean trips like that that do not help your fitness at all.
Like they won't help you climb harder,
but they definitely make you a more well rounded climber and probably a better
person and more understanding you had to do fun stuff.
And so you know,
I've heard have been content being plateaued at that mid five 14 for a long time
though I could see at some point in my life I might devote a year or two to like
actually trying to climb hard cause I'd love to climb the,
the French grade nine a which has 14 d and u s grades.
Um,
it's just sort of like a meaningful benchmark grade that if I ever climbed nine,
eight I'd be like respect.
Like I'm good.
Like that's,
that's hard enough
for me.
So if you wanted to do that hard climbing,
what would the most important components of that training look like?
Um,
I'm not totally sure.
I mean,
I think for me it would require more finger boarding or hang boarding,
like basically just focusing more on finger strength because I think as a
climber that's probably what I'm worst at is just like the pure strength holding
onto things.
Um,
but also I think for me it would just require more dedicated focused,
the hard climbing for the year.
You know,
like right now I'm climbing in Yosemite and a in my whole season of climbing you
70,
I won't do a single hard move basically at the,
you know,
at the physical limit of like what I can actually pull on because I'm climbing
these,
that great big walls and I'm trying to climb the quickly and sometimes I'm
climbing them rope lists.
But anyway,
I'm doing,
I'm an all these styles that like just doesn't help you pull harder.
And so like if I wanted to climb harder grades,
I would have to just pull harder.
If you could no longer climb but had to pick a physical activity,
what would you pick?
If I couldn't climb?
I don't know.
I have a lot of respect for ultra runners I think.
Um,
because they sort of interact with the landscape in the same way that I kind of
liked to,
you know,
like the something like the ultra two or mobile when you like run all the way
around the MONTBLANC messy.
I mean that's pretty cool.
And like I would love to be able to do things like that,
but I just like don't really,
I can't run that well,
but um,
but the thing is is that I really love running like mountain ridge lines and
things and then that quickly becomes actual rock climbing.
And so I'm like,
well,
it's like,
I dunno.
But yeah,
ultra running is pretty awesome.
Um,
I dunno,
I can be ended like big mountain skiing too.
Like same,
but see it all sorta gravitates back towards mountains and I'm like,
well that's basically climbing.
When did you get exposed to nasty things like avalanches for those of you who
haven't seen marrow?
Jesus.
Jimmy,
both of you guys make me sweat.
Not that I needed any help.
I have tend to run hot drink a tea anyway,
but uh,
yeah,
I digress.
As usual.
Uh,
what are you world class at,
aside from climbing or within climbing that people might not realize?
Um,
or how would your best friends answer that question?
I don't know.
I mean,
I guess one that within climbing I'd say that,
um,
cause I'm known as a free soul,
just I'm known for the rope was climbing and that's like what you'll see online
and you know,
all the videos and all that.
But I'd probably still be a professional climber even if I didn't free solo at
all.
Um,
like right now I hold the speed record on like pretty much every major
formation.
And you,
somebody,
um,
you know,
all the different faces,
like all the classic routes.
Um,
I,
I mean I think that's basically true.
And so,
yeah,
I don't know.
I mean I'd probably still be like one of the more well rounded climbers in
America,
even without the free soloing.
But,
um,
but it's all sort of overshadowed by the like,
oh my God,
he's Rueplus.
And it's funny because I only do,
you know,
a handful of solos a year if that.
And then I spend the whole rest of the year climbing with partners and ropes and
like normal climate with my friends.
Just like doing all kinds of interesting things and expeditions and whatever.
And yet it still just comes down to like,
Whoa,
free soloing.
But you know,
I'm fine with that because at least I could do a climb all the time.
What advice would you give to your 25 year old self?
25 or 20 depending on who needed it the most.
And if you could just place like what you were doing and where you were at the
time.
Well 20 is still slightly too old,
but like my 18 year old self,
I should just tell them.
I would say it does not bother going to college at all.
Cause like the year that I spent at Berkeley,
it was a total waste of my time.
Basically.
Not,
not because there's anything wrong with Berkeley,
but because I just wasn't passionate about what I was studying.
And there's no,
there,
there was no point in me like grinding out a year of studies that I didn't care
about that,
you know,
I should have just like gone call me.
Cause I mean that's what I really cared about.
And that's what's been so funny over the years is that like with climbing,
you know,
I have no problem putting in,
20 to 40 hours a week,
every week,
all year and declining like,
and I mean that's a fair amount.
I,
I've been keeping a trading journal.
Um,
so I have like sort of hours of exercise and last year,
um,
I counted up at the end of the,
at the new year and a,
I basically averaged like 27 hours a week of exercise every week last year,
which is,
you know,
like,
I think that's kind of comparable to others.
I mean,
you would know more than me,
but other sports like for training volume.
But I mean,
and then when you think that I've probably been doing that for the last 10
years.
I've been on the road and actually,
and last year was a particularly low volume year for me because I had a book
come out and so I did a month of book touring and I also did like a month of
touring and South America.
And so like I was climbing much less than I normally would.
So presumably a few years ago living in the van I was probably doing like 30,
probably 30 or 32 hours a week of exercise,
which is like a lot of times spent climbing and has a lot of time.
But what else do you put in your trading journal?
What other details are in there?
Um,
it's one lot.
I do one line hours of exercise,
one line,
um,
any additional like strength training type stuff or like the stretching on the
new recently and then one line diet,
which is like eight,
well eight poorly eight toso or like,
you know,
too many cookies,
like whatever,
things like that.
Do you go back to you,
you don't have cookies?
Sometimes of an unfortunate.
What's what's,
what's your go to cookie?
Should I just talk to him?
Could you just like straight?
I can eat a lot of cookies.
Yeah.
Well that's probably the only thing that athletically it will not that we share
in common.
Oh yeah.
Do you go big on the cookie too?
Yeah.
There's,
you're looking towards your car.
While I was looking at it,
it's like secret stash.
I have to keep it at a site.
Yeah.
There are these chocolate chip cookies,
uh,
that are actually from long island Tate's.
I think they are.
There's going to be like nodding over there with important chocolate chip cookie
originally from Long Island and they have theirs.
They're chocolate chip cookies.
Then there are these,
I think they're gluten free ginger cookies and I can't have those in my house or
demolish the,
that's my thing with desserts too is I don't really buy it as much because if I
buy it,
I just eat it all immediately.
Like I'm terrible with moderation.
So I generally don't have any dessert in the van.
And then when I do,
I just eat it all.
If you were to,
I know this
is,
this is a bit of a reach,
but you're 30 now,
let's say your idealized 40 year old self,
right?
Uh,
what advice do you think that 40 year old would give you now?
I Dunno.
I mean I feel like I'm doing pretty well right now.
I'm not saying you're not just,
yeah,
no I don't.
I Dunno.
I mean just,
you know,
just enjoy the ride,
enjoy the process.
Uh,
what would you like to your life to look like in 10 years?
Um,
I don't know.
I mean maybe have a family or something or at least like a solid partner,
solid something going on.
Um,
I think I'd like to maybe own a home or like have,
have a place that I'm kind of living like more of a solid home base just because
like living in a van is great,
but you know,
at a certain point you're like,
man,
it's nice to have like a bathroom,
but I'm having like a shower things.
How do you deal with that?
And actually now that,
that's why when I came into your house,
I use your bathroom.
That's getting less.
So like last night you're like,
Oh man,
I had too much water.
I have no,
I have a pee bottle.
I mean you know I've used a bottle forever and actually the thing is when you
get used to using a pee bottle all the time,
like when I pull into a grocery store or something,
I always just like p and my bottle before I go into that,
you know,
cause you're like why would I ever go and find some like Dank public bathroom
when like I can just use my bottle.
It's like,
do you have,
do you have a,
is it a disposable pee bottle?
Like a tsunami I use,
I use like a two liter bottle,
just like some random plastic bottle and I basically use it over and over until
it's like this is repulsive.
And then I recycle it and then I move on to another.
But it's actually kind of that this is natural.
It's the natural life cycle because I'll use the same water bottle for climbing.
It'll just be like some random two liter bottle that's in my bag for like
months.
And then eventually it starts to get disgusting or just kind of,
you know,
a little gross.
And so then I'm like,
well,
that becomes the pee bottle and then I get another bottle.
It's like the four month cycle on my bottles,
you know.
Do you label them or do you know?
Yeah,
with a pee bottle.
You just know,
like,
you know,
when you open a bottle you're like,
oh,
I can drink this.
But also I've systems with like where things go and you know,
I'm never going to accidentally like drink my people on them.
Uh,
do you have,
do people visit you in your van?
Like hang out in your van aside from the dates?
Um,
yeah,
no,
I mean,
friends hanging out in my van for sure.
a lot of my climbing friends would be staying in a tent,
normally are staying wherever.
So I mean for them it's a big step up to hang out in the van.
It's like climate controlled,
you know,
you can,
it's like sheltered.
You can cook on a nice stove.
It's lit.
I mean,
it's a nice place to hang out in the evenings.
Uh,
if you could have one billboard with anything on it,
what would it say or what would you put on it?
Just can get a message to the world.
Oh,
I dunno.
I mean,
it's like,
it just like,
I dunno,
environmental propaganda or something or like,
uh,
the Meta,
I'm like pretty stuck and all the vegetarian type of stuff now just because it's
such an easy way to minimize your impact on the planet and it's just,
I mean,
it just solves so many different environmental issues,
but,
um,
I don't know.
But the thing is a billboard is not the best way to just say don't eat meat
because it's like,
it's obviously a lot more complicated than that and nobody's going to read that
and be like,
oh,
okay,
I'll stop.
Right.
You know,
it's like requires more of a conversation.
Yeah.
I mean,
it requires like a hole in,
and even then it's like,
it's not in to say that like meat is fundamentally bad.
It's like how you get it,
where it's from,
what you're supporting.
I mean,
you know,
it's like a whole feed lot versus this versus,
yeah.
I mean even that it's like really complicated because there are places in the
world where it makes sense to,
to raise animals cause like you can't raise anything else,
you can't grow crops,
you know,
whatever.
And so,
uh,
what have you changed your mind about in the last few years,
if anything?
Um,
I mean the first thing that comes to mind is like in high school I was reading a
bunch of iron rand or and rand,
whatever,
you know,
like objectivist,
all super black and white basically like f the poor people should work harder,
they should try harder.
And now as a 30 year old on basically like all about trying to help the poor and
trying to help the planet in different ways,
trying to make the world a better place.
It's like a full 180 from,
you know,
the black and white that I was into it in high school.
And then,
yeah,
I mean I've had massive changes on all those kinds of things.
I mean I used to be way more harsh,
you know,
and like my political views are like way further left now.
I'm just way more,
I mean I'm a lot more compassionate now.
I feel like those 20 not so much on a personal level cause I don't that you're
put on like a societal level.
I'm a lot more compassionate.
It's saying I can't let that one go right away cause I was like,
I can't self describe as compassionate because none of my friends would agree.
You know?
Cause the thing is I've not like nice to like my friends are on like a one on
one level.
I'm not like a super kind person I don't think.
But um,
but definitely in the grander sense.
I mean I'm trying to make,
I'm,
I aspire to make the world a better place and like a more,
more just world,
you know,
on the macro level.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's still high level.
So if I took say a couple of your closest friends and gave them a bottle or two
of wine or just hanging out,
how would they describe you?
Oh,
I dunno,
I
shutter to think.
Well,
I mean the thing,
I'm pretty frank I think.
And so people can,
you know,
think I can kind of be a dick sometimes.
And um,
though I just consider that being very honest.
You know,
we keep it real.
Yeah.
I'm just keeping it real,
keeping it real.
I mean,
I'd like to think that my friends would still call me a good person,
you know,
that I'm still like still trying to,
I'm doing my best to uh,
give any,
we're going to wrap up here.
Any ask or request for my audience and that could be something you want them to
think about.
Somebody you would like them to try something like that to do.
I feel like they're all MMA fighters.
I'd ask them to ask them not to beat me up,
but
I should,
I don't know,
do something positive in the world,
you know,
not a bad place to wrap up.
Where can people find more of you online place to say hello,
see what you're up to?
Um,
I mean my most personal outlet is probably my Facebook fan page and my
constantly posting stuff that I care about and it's all managed by me.
And so it was just like me posting articles that I think are interesting.
It's kind of like a combination of,
of uh,
the climate stuff that I'm into.
And then like the environmental stuff that I'm into,
basically I post the environmental stuff is all the stuff I care about.
And then I post just enough climates that everyone doesn't leave.
And a is that what,
what is the URL for that and an approach to the facebook.com/alex Honnold I
think.
Okay.
But if you just search search word is,
you know,
like a fan page.
It's like several hundred thousand people or whatever each o.
N.
O.
L.
D.
Yeah.
Well,
Alex,
I really appreciate you taking the time.
I've been hoping to meet you for a long time,
given that we're not that far apart,
oftentimes with a Yosemite.
So present.
This is,
uh,
this has been fun.
And once I,
once I fixed my elbows,
maybe I'll see if I can tack.
Yeah,
you should be zero
and maybe actually getting out of the doors,
which I would enjoy it.
So,
uh,
I will,
hopefully do more than a three day meditation retreat given that you've been
doing it for 20 years,
but extend my ambition a little bit,
but thanks very much.
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for having me.
Pleasure and everybody listening for show notes,
links to everything that we talked about.
Please just go to four hour work week.com forward slash podcast and until next
time,
as always,
thank you for listening.
Hey guys,
this is Tim again.
Just a few more things before you take off.
Number one.
This is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short email from me every Friday that provides a
little more soul of fun before the weekend and five bullet Friday is a very
short email where I share the coolest things I've found or that I've been
pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the,
uh,
the world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's four hour workweek.com all spelled out
and just drop in your email and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought to you by headspace.
More than 80% of the people I have interviewed,
world class performers across the military,
entertainment,
sports,
and beyond all have some type of meditative practice.
I tried for years and years and failed miserably.
The key is making it simple and you can dramatically improve your life in just
10 minutes a day and can help you.
This change comes through guided meditation and headspace is by far the most
popular app for this purpose.
More than 4 million users.
It's meditation made simple.
So what I recommend is that you take this practice meditation,
which is rooted in thousands of years of tradition,
supported by thousands of scientific studies and try it for 10 minutes a day for
10 days.
That's all you need to do.
You could also check out the founder Andy Puddicombe,
a Ted talk,
which has more than 5.5 million views.
His last name is p U.
Do you want to look that up?
But otherwise download the free headspace APP.
I have it on my phone and begin their take 10 program for 10 days of guided
meditation.
Completely free.
10 minutes a day.
That's all it takes.
You should give it a shot.
headspace.com forward slash Tim just go to headspace.com forward slash
so it is brought to you by 99 designs when your business needs a logo,
website,
business card,
thumbnail,
or any other design.
I recommend checking out 99 designs.
I use them myself.
I've used them for many years.
I used them to create book cover prototypes for the four hour body,
which went on to becoming number one New York Times bestseller.
I've also used them for banner ads,
illustrations,
and much more.
With 99 designs.
You get a variety of original designs from designers around the world,
give your feedback and then pick your favorite.
Your happiness is guaranteed.
It's a checkout some of my competitions in designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss.
Show listeners@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim and right now you can get
a free $99 upgrade on your first design to check it out,
99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim,
and until next time,
thank you for listening.
Yeah.